est un peu plus de 22h pour cette soirée
électorale spéciale législatif 2022
décryptage analyse avec de nouveaux
invités ainsi évidemment que notre
dispositif en région nos envoyés
spéciaux sont toujours fidèles au poste
vous allez les voir sur sa fiche est à
l'antenne les voilà ça c'était lamendin
gabao vient de voir marco pommiers qui
est à baupte verne a vu nicolas coadou
là c'était mario becker pardonnez moi et
l'a fait stéphanie à des pierres nous
sommes donc à la fois dans le vaucluse
mais aussi à oyonnax nous sommes dans le
calvados également bref on vous donne la
parole dans quelques minutes avec moi
sur ce plateau pour cette dernière ligne
droite
d'explication de ce second tour yves
thréard bonsoir bonsoir ravi d'être avec
vous ce soir éditorialiste au figaro
pierre latry vous êtes fidèle au poste
on a besoin de votre éclairage ipsos
sopra steria catherine tricot bienvenus
ravi de vous accueillir directrice des
éditions regard et roland cayrol roland
cayrol qu'on ne présente plus
politologue très fin observateur de la
vie politique française ça fait deux
trois heures que vous observez ses
résultats à la loupe je voudrais vous
entendre pour vous quel est le fait
marquant de la soirée est ce qu'il y à
un vainqueur yves therrien
je sais pas si un vainqueur va d'abord
parce que c'est que le premier tour il
faut attendre le deuxième tour il faut
aller dans le détail des des débuts
scrutin est d'aider des circonscriptions
simplement ce qu'on peut dire c'est que
le président de la république n'a pas
gagné cette élection en tous les cas il
est en difficulté on est dans un
contexte radicalement différent de celui
de 2010 est qu'il avait largement dominé
on continue à voir quand même cette
plaie et moi cesser le danger qui est
énorme qui est celle de l'abstention
puisque quand même il faut pas l'oublier
c'est
cent des français ont
voter seulement enfin à peu près 1 selon
les instituts qui nous donne les
chiffres mais c'est quand même terrible
on est dans une élection législative
c'est-à-dire une élection nationale avec
des enjeux nationaux avec est bien le
fait que cette élection se situe juste
dans le prolongement de la
présidentielle depuis maintenant 20 ans
eh bien je suis pas sûr que ce soit une
très bonne chose la deuxième chose c'est
quand même la poussée très forte avec le
on va pas dire le coup de génie mais le
coup médiatique réussie néanmoins il
faut le dire de jean luc mélenchon il a
réussi vous dites poussée très forte ce
soir oui mais vous a il faut le dire en
voie il est au coude à coude et en lutte
et un show et sa coalition avec à sa
disette de la regarder ce qu'on disait
de la gauche il n'y a pas très longtemps
encore
il a réussi quelque chose alors après on
peut qualifier cette grille je reçois
cette question parce que avant vous il y
avait beaucoup de gens qui vivaient
finalement ça n'est qu'une addition des
forces de gauche je n'avais pas de
dynamique mais à ce moment-là à beauvau
on peut aussi additionner des forces du
centre oui bon à ce petit jeu là je
crois pas que beauvau joue gagnant ce
qui est intéressant c'est de voir que
cette gauche qui en france sous la vème
république a toujours été tirée par une
gauche socialiste social démocrate là
elle est tirée justement par une gauche
plus radicale que cela et qui est domine
largement de la tête et des épaules
cézallier d'ailleurs parce que faudrait
regarder dans le détail mais le parti
socialiste est quand même pas en très
bon état les verts ont bien du mal à
tirer leur épingle du jeu quand ton
parti communiste ils sont non plus pas
non plus dans un très très bon donc
c'est la victoire de jean luc mélenchon
mais attendez jamais d'argent il sort de
cette législature avec 17
députés là il en aura vraisemblablement
peut-être 115 pas fou pour lui même pas
pour lui-même pour cent par an si les
insoumis peut-être cinq à six fois plus
donc c'est quand même
voilà un sabot mistral éditorialiste de
saint paul à jean luc mélenchon qui
l'aurait cru le figaro qui salue leur
monitrice à lui perçu reconnaît tu
reconnais l'exploit politique de jean
luc mélenchon 4 et rabaud je pense en
effet qu'il ya quelques mois on pensait
que la gauche était absolument défaite
on n'imaginait pas son résultat le
résultat de jean luc mélenchon à
l'élection présidentielle au premier
tour et encore moins le résultat qui
vient d'avoir lieu ce soir on imagine et
encore moins l'alliance de toutes les
forces de gauche et que ça puisse
produire le résultat de ce soir la
deuxième est élément quand même qui est
assez notoire c'est que emmanuel macron
quelques semaines après son élection à
l'élection présidentielle recul c'est à
dire qu'on est il passe de 28 à 25 %
c'est à dire qu'on y est on a reculé en
pourcentage en nombre de voix et il est
en difficulté il n'aura probablement pas
la majorité absolue ça semble maintenant
quand même très très compromis alors oui
tout à fait mais ce que ce que j'étais
en train de discuter avec mon ami juste
avant c'est qu'en fait quand on commence
à regarder circonscription par
circonscription il y aura énormément de
duels qui vont être nulle ensemble c'est
à dire la gauche face au rassemblent
entre 300 et 350 duels voilà ça va être
ça va être ça qui va dominer le second
tout donc on ne sait pas quelle
dynamique qui va y avoir en ceci étant
au premier tour on peut dire que la
dynamique a été davantage à gauche et
que emmanuel macron a eu bien du mal à
relancer la campagne de son camp et que
dans cette dynamique l'idée de se faire
le président du groupe la première
ministre à ministre par ci et cetera et
cetera des ans des députés sortants
parce qu'il y à l'envi d'en découdre
profondément dans vos cahiers à la
dynamique à moi je crois et je vois la
diva continuer louis lauzon moi je pense
et moi je viendrai les abstentions lui
je la tue aura une voix il y aura six à
la réserve de voix des catégories
populaires dans le camp mélenchon et
cette année c'était le sens je crois de
son discours ce soir roland cayrol votre
analyse de ce warm up pour répondre à
votre question sur les vainqueurs je
dirais il ya deux vainqueurs
incontestables avant d'entrer dans la
politique il ya l'abstention est
l'abstention ça m'inquiète parce que on
est on a pris l'habitude on bat les
records d'abstention à chaque soirée
électorale donc on a pris l'habitude
d'avoir ça il en a pris l'habitude
d'avoir des larmes de crocodile versée
par les différents partis politiques sur
le fait que dans une démocratie c'est
quand même et pour un temps un sur la
chaîne parlementaire oui voilà de
s'attarder pour essayer de comprendre au
delà du conjoncturel ce qui se passait
dans le pays bas aussi puisque j'ai fait
un documentaire sur votre choix nous
étions à leur faisait penser à leurs
abords mais au delà des soirées
électorales ou on pleure après on fait
rien
on n'a pas de vraies propositions des
partis des institutions françaises pour
savoir comment lutter contre ça alors
j'espère que cette fois-ci vous les
obligerait à un peu dans les temps qui
viennent à donner des propositions faire
parce que suffit pas de dire c'est
dommage on n'y est pour rien ils s'y
sont touche pour quelque chose deuxième
vaincu les sondages ils ont bien analysé
la campagne ils ont bien mesuré
quatre ils ont bien mesuré les
dynamiques fin voilà ils en prennent
suffisamment plein la figure de temps en
temps pour que quand ça marche il
fallait il fallait leur dirait jack
heures parmi les forces arrivé en tête
alors sur les faces arrivé en tête moi
je crois qu'il faut faire très attention
le soir de premier tour aux
enthousiasmes des uns et des autres ou
enthousiasme des uns et la réserve des
autres je crois réellement que une
élection à deux tours ça n'est pas fini
avant le deuxième tour c'est lapalissade
mais c'est vraiment vrai par exemple
j'entends macro n'a pas fait autant que
qu'il avait fait à la présidentielle
d'accord mélenchon non plus le total des
voix de gauche n'est pas atteint de la
présidentielle n'est pas atteint par la
nuque alors on ne peut pas avoir un
regard différent avec des critères
différents selon les partis politiques
il ya un succès puisque il très rare le
dire on est bien forcé de tous suivre
yves traire notre maître à tous donc il
serait rannou dit il à son cou à marcher
son coût a pas mal marché faut il nous
avait annoncé 500 duels je les vois pas
ma femme et on met donc 350 se soit déjà
bien à redonner moi de vous interrompre
roland cayrol donne la parole tout de
suite kathia gilder richard ferrand est
à votre micro dans le finistère le
président de l'assemblée nationale qui
remet son mandat de député au jour
absolument myriam je suis avec richard
ferrand ici dans cette 6ème
circonscription du finistère bonsoir
richard ferrand bonsoir
arrivé en tête de votre circonscription
dans votre fief mais alors vous êtes
talonné de près par la candidate qui
représente la gauche unie vous êtes dans
quel état d'esprit serait serein ou
inquiets concentrez vous savez être
optimiste ou pessimiste ne sert à rien
c'est qu'il faut c'est être
concentré se dire qu'on est placé en
tête qui est un signal fort de la part
de l'électorat la 6e circonscription du
finistère donc avec ma suppléante années
que morvan et bien nous allons consacrer
notre semaine a rassemblé à convaincre
et à mobiliser abstentionnistes
notamment et quelle sera votre stratégie
face à ces les électeurs qui se sont
notamment portés nombreux vers 1 mélanie
thomas votre première concurrente
aujourd'hui qui est une femme de gauche
quelle sera votre stratégie
d'abord je n'ai pas de stratégie contre
j'ai une démarche pour est ce que je me
dis c'est que les finistériennes et des
finistériens savent au fond d'eux que le
président république a besoin d'une
majorité solide stable et fiable pour à
la fois porter son projet et porter les
valeurs qui sont les siennes or
aujourd'hui ce soir nous savons qu'il y
a deux projets diamétralement opposées
un système de valeurs
diamétralement opposées et par
conséquent le choix sera faire de la
manière la plus claire la semaine
prochaine et c'est de cela dont nous
allons parler cette semaine à l'ensemble
des électrices et les électeurs de notre
circonscription c'est ainsi j'en suis
convaincu que nous allons les convaincre
sans préjuger du futur visage de
l'assemblée nationale à l'issue du 19
juin vous qui êtes président de
l'assemblée nationale est ce que vous
prévoyez quand vous regardez ce
déferlement de députés nuque qui
aujourd'hui sont un petit groupe mais
qui risque de passer à plus de 100
comment comment vous voyez elle c'est
arrivé ce que ça vous inquiète est ce
que vous redoutez une une assemblée
ingouvernable si je puis dire
d'abord il n'ya pas de déferlement
il y à un premier tour à l'issue duquel
se sont d'abord des candidates et les
candidats de la majorité qui sont en
plus grand nombre au second tour moi je
ne crains aucun déferlement puisqu'il
n'y en aura pas
ça c'est le premier point ensuite les
françaises et les français se dote des
représentants qu'il souhaite et ensuite
l'assemblée a vocation à vivre dans le
respect des uns et des autres comme pour
ma part j'ai toujours contribué à faire
que chacun puisse s'exprimer avec équité
et que les différents points de vue
soient confrontés qu'ensuite le texte
soit adopté il faut pas craindre des
discussions du projet loi difficile avec
une majorité un peu ric-rac si je puis
dire moi je ne spécule pas sur le
résultat ce qui est clair c'est que
aujourd'hui il y à un système de valeurs
qui est diamétralement opposée et des
projets qui sont diamétralement opposées
entre ce que porte non pas la gauche car
je vous rappelle que j'en fais partie de
la gauche c'est quand même pas mélenchon
qui va donner des brevets de gauche
c'est l'homme de gauche qui passe bah
oui tout simplement donc c'est pas lui
qui va breveté qui est de gauche qu'il
n'est pas etc la question est de savoir
qui adhère à un projet progressiste qui
adhèrent à la construction européenne et
non pas à une europe à la carte qui
préfèrent l'otan à poutine etc etc et
ensuite évidemment c'est de confronter
toutes les conséquences qu'aurait tel ou
tel choix est bien c'est de cela dont
nous allons débattre avec des électrices
et les électeurs dans les jours qui
viennent pendant toute la semaine merci
beaucoup richard ferrand d'avoir été en
direct pour lcp dans cette sixième
circonscription du finistère qui est la
plus grande de france merci à vous merci
à vous kathia gilder
roland cayrol c'est intéressant parce
que on a un ancien socialiste richard
ferrand pendant des années qui se
retrouve talonnée par une candidate
emmené par la coalition de jean luc
mélenchon lui même ancien socialiste
ironie de l'histoire il ne pense plus du
tout la même chose si un jour ils ont
même partagé des idées en commun mais
quand même qu'est ce que ça dit de la
recomposition
dit justement ça ça dit que vraiment il
s'est placé depuis 2010 est quelque
chose d'assez
profonde
organisation partisane dans ce pays et
que 2022 rajoute encore une couche à 7 à
cet événement et ça n'a plus beaucoup
d'importance pour eux d'avoir été ancien
socialiste ancien machin ce qui compte
aujourd'hui c'est leur positionnement
dans l'actuel rapport de force catherine
tricot mais moi ce que je trouve très
étonnant c'est les entendre d'entendre
les candidats deux ensembles parler de
la coalition de gauche comme des
extrêmes c'est-à-dire en mettant
dos-à-dos l'extrême droite et la gauche
c'est à dire que là il ya quand même des
parallèles et il ya des digues morales
qui me paraissent incroyables
comment peuvent-ils faire ça et c'est
pas du tout c'était pas du tout
l'attitude qu'avait eue emmanuel mc hale
à l'issue du premier tour il avait quand
même fait tous les appels à la gauche en
leur disant même que les bourgeons leur
vie valait mieux qu aux filles qui ont
tous un profil et à l'assemblée c'est la
renaissance de clivage gauche-droite
soeur alors ça je le crois mais par
ailleurs ce que je trouve étonnant c'est
que ça se fasse au détriment de une
limite qui avait toujours été posée on a
entendu tout à l'heure jean michel
blanquer faire des leçons sur la
démocratie et la république enfin la
république ça donnait une limite c'est l
extrême droite et là on est en train de
mettre la gauche de dire que la gauche
égalent l'extrême droite et que ce sont
des extrêmes c'est-à-dire que tout
devient banale celle une banalisation de
l'extrême droite que je trouve
incroyable et que l'on entende des
anciens socialistes parler de l'union de
la gauche comme des extrêmes là je
trouve qu'on est dans le coup fut gérée
à m'avoir vu laurent garnier que ça me
paraît très préjudiciable par rapport
justement aux valeurs de la république
25,6 pour cent et des voix pour la nuque
ça fait 25 0% dans l'accord de s'en
priver de la politique
moi je suis pas du tout d'accord avec ce
que vous venez de dire absolument pas
d'accord parce que tout a changé tout a
complètement été bouleversée je dirais
et moi je mets pas sur la même longueur
d'onde de madame le pen et monsieur
mélenchon ce que je peux vous dire c'est
qu'il ya plus de formations politiques
et si on regarde bien le paysage
aujourd'hui vous avez un pays qui est
divisé en quatre quarts moi je me réfère
à l'élection présidentielle un quart des
abstentionnistes un cas qui votent pour
le candidat
macron qui est un candidat on va dire du
centrisme bon teint et puis
un quart qui a voté pour mais mélenchon
et ce carré beaucoup constitué d'une
gauche assez radical c'est une bouche
radical et je suis désolé ce qu'on nous
présente aujourd'hui à l'occasion de ces
élections législatives le ps le pc les
verts il fonde et ils font de la
figuration
s'il n'y avait pas eu ce mélenchon mais
il serait dans le fossé tout cela
n'existerait plus donc c'est quand même
mélenchon et mélenchon c'est un discours
extrêmement radical c'était
robespierristes on va vous mettre
d'accord là dessus et on va ouvrir ce
débat là d'un autre âge mais pas d'âme
et le quatrième quart évidemment et pas
berner par madame le pen qui n'a pas
fait campagne qui est partie défaitiste
dans cette qu'il s'en tire pas si mal ce
soir qu'il s'en tire pas si mal et ça
pourrait être beaucoup mieux pour elle à
je ne cherche pas à plaider son dossier
mais si elle avait fait à peu près la
même occupation médiatique que monsieur
mélenchon peut-être qu'elle aurait alors
brillé davantage mais encore une fois je
suis complètement d'accord avec roland
il faut pas s'emballer s'est pas
terminée c'est le sens terminent à
réfléchir aux projections de second tour
où sont les réserves de voix quels sont
les dynamiques possible d'abord on va
accueillir clément pernot qui va revenir
sur le nouveau visage de l'hémicycle en
ce que l'on peut en dire ce qui
s'esquisse en vue du deuxième tour
projection en nombre de sièges voilà je
vous propose myriam de prendre quelques
instants maintenant pour nous plonger
dans le visage que pourraient avoir les
mii cycle après ces élections alors
cette projection elle est basée sur les
estimations de notre partenaire ipsos le
bloc le plus important il apparaît en
violet vous le voyez ce sont les
candidats ce sont les députés qui
soutiennent emmanuel macron les députés
ensemble ils seraient entre 255 et 295
ils étaient 3 146 lors de la législature
précédente il ya donc une érosion
importante je vous rappelle que la
majorité absolue elle est à 289 sièges
elle est donc pour le moment très loin
d'être acquise pour ensemble le second
bloc le plus important vous le voyez ici
en rouge c'est la nuque 150 à 190 sièges
ce sera sans doute insuffisant pour
obtenir une majorité absolue mais sa
marque une sacrée progression jusqu'ici
le bloc de gauche comptait 60 députés
maintenant allons voir à droite de
l'hémicycle couleur bleue 50 à 80
députés là aussi il ya une érosion pour
la droite qui comptait jusqu'ici 119
députés enfin un nouveau groupe fait son
apparition vous le voyez à droite en
bleu foncé presque noir c'est le
rassemblement national qui compterait 20
à 45 députés ce qui serait largement
suffisant pour constituer un groupe
parlementaire merci beaucoup clément
perreault on va parler de ce groupe
ensemble parce que la donne politique
est importante ce soir quand on voit les
rapports de force en sensibilité tiens
en voilà un maquereau nist qui ce soir
est en ballottage favorable mais qui a
peut-être un peu de souci à se faire en
vue du second tour c'est christophe
castaner on va l'écouter depuis son fief
de forcalquier
ne faut pas regarder les résultats comme
étant les résultats acquis les choses
bougent dans une élection législative
entre les deux tours nous avons dans ma
circonscription comme partout ailleurs
la capacité à mobiliser les français qui
veulent de l'ordre et pas du désordre
qui ne veulent pas d'une déferlante pour
reprendre les mots de jean luc mélenchon
qui d'ailleurs ne se renouvelle pas
beaucoup parce que j'ai le souvenir qu'à
l'automne 2010 est qu'on nous réformer
en profondeur le travail et l'accès au
travail pour faire en sorte
qu'aujourd'hui nous soyons le premier
pays en termes d'attractivité pour faire
en sorte que la perspective du
plein-emploi sa possible aujourd'hui
dans notre pays il nous annonçait à
l'époque chaque semaine une déferlante
pour empêcher de mettre à niveau et de
moderniser notre pays donc il ne change
pas moi je ne veux pas d'une déferlante
je veux au contraire de l'ordre et
l'ordre est nécessaire dans notre
république voilà christophe castaner
depuis paris vous avez sans doute
reconnu le sel de france télévisions et
pas dans son fief des alpes de haute
provence yves thréard là on va avoir un
entre-deux tours très clair la majorité
va taper sur mélenchon et vice versa ça
va durer une semaine est ce que vous
pensez que chef de l'état lui-même doit
s'engager on l'a vu dans la dernière
ligne droite de avant le premier tour le
faire
est-ce que elisabeth borne peut incarner
ce
position de chef de la majorité pour
mobiliser son temps alors ça va être
très intéressant alors pour revenir en
deux secondes sur christophe castaner il
faut pas oublier que c'est une
circonscription du luberon qui est une
circonscription de gauche très marqué à
gauche c'est le luberon c'est pas le
luberon de chiffres de l'acoss t2 c'est
pas du tout ça c'est le luberon beaucoup
plus quel jour était à gauche et
d'ailleurs c'est un ancien député de
gauche de socialistes après vous me
parlez de la semaine à venir alors la
semaine dernière est assez intéressante
parce que vous avez un agenda du
président de la république qui est
essentiellement internationale il doit
partir pour la moldavie la roumanie déjà
et la moldavie la roumanie peut-être
peut-être l'ukraine il ya aussi des
obligations européennes et il est
président de l'union du conseil de
l'union européenne et donc ça va être
intéressant de savoir comment il va
pouvoir concilier les deux je ne le vois
pas ne pas parler des élections
législatives compte tenu de la soirée
qui n'est pas extraordinaire pour lui
parce que y'a encore que vous pensez que
ça peut être bien perçu entre les deux
tours à nouveau s'engager comme il l'a
fait s'impliquent je sais pas je ne suis
pas à sa place et c'est pas moi qui vais
diriger cette campagne électorale en
tous les cas y en a une qui est engagée
c'est madame board et qui est candidate
donc on va voir ce que les uns et les
autres vont pouvoir dire combien on va
partir dans le calvados dans un instant
roland cayrol
cayrol pardonnez moi vous pensez que
c'est à isabelle borne de s'engager ou à
emmanuel macron tués il est évident que
le seul véritable chef de la majorité
c'est manuel macron elle a beaucoup de
qualités sûrement elisabeth bornes mais
c'est pas elle qui va enflammer les
tréteaux les consciences donc évidemment
il faut qu'il parle alors est-ce qu'il
va y arriver son agenda est c'est vrai
assez compliqué mais moi je dirais d'un
point de vue purement d'observateurs il
doit y arriver ces sacs la campagne
électorale s'est devrait être là
l'assiette puisque c'est lui qui est
mise en cause c'est lui trois mêmes
depuis il a besoin d'une majorité pour
gouverner
il a donc besoin d'aller la chercher
alors direction la normandie le calvados
où hélène bonduelle nous attend l'as
wihr ceylac elisabeth bornes je vous le
disais se présente pour la première fois
vous avez des résultats à nous
communiquer
exactement meriam un instant et bien les
résultats définitifs elisabeth borne est
donc qualifié avec 34% des voix pour le
second tour elle sera face au candidat
de la nuque nos égos chars qui se
qualifie avec 24% des voix le candidat
du rassemblement national est arrivé
troisième il est éliminé alors c'est
trois points de moins que son
prédécesseur pour elisabeth bornes dans
cette circonscription mais l'essentiel
pour elle c'est qu'elle soit qualifiée
parce que vous le savez elles jouent
gros elisabeth bornes dans cette
circonscription que si elle n'est pas
élue et bien elle pourrait perdre son
poste à matignon alors son équipe de
campagne puisque isabelle borne allait
retourner à paris pour suivre ses
résultats son équipe de campagne qui
était au qg tout à l'heure est sorti
avant même les résultats définitifs pour
saluer cette accession au second tout
pour se féliciter elle est prête à
ferrailler son adversaire est prête à
ferrailler avec est légalement il nous a
dit je n'ai pas peur de faire face à la
première ministre elisabeth bornes qui
était encore à paris mais qui rentre ce
soir très tard ici à vire elle sera dès
demain en campagne sur le terrain à
condé sur noireau exactement une
vingtaine de kilomètres d'ici dans sa
circonscription en route pour la
campagne du second tour campagne entre
matignon et le calvados vous êtes en
direct merci à vous hélène bonduelle on
va partir avec marion becker à oyonnax
vous savez qu'à 15 ministres en course
dans cette législative c'est le cas de
dany damien abad dont on connaît les
difficultés suite aux accusations de
viol dont il a dont il a fait l'objet
les résultats marion becker
et bien damien abad est arrivé largement
en tête avec plus de 33 % des voix
devant la candidate de la nuque florence
pisani qui elle a un peu moins de 24% en
troisième position le rassemblement
national un peu plus de 19 % et enfin le
candidat de la droite le candidat les
républicains avec est presque 10%
damien abad est donc dans une situation
de ballotage favorable pour ce second
tour il est arrivé ici en mairie
d'oyonnax vers 20h30 visiblement très
soulagé par ce résultat il est venu
remercier ses soutiens qu'ils l'ont
applaudi chaleureusement ici en tout cas
le ministre est resté assez modeste en
appelant les électeurs de sa
circonscription à se mobiliser à
continuer à voter et surtout ne pas
s'abstenir pour le second tour damien
abad désormais ministre des solidarités
et du handicap qui joue gros puisque
s'il perd il devra également quitter le
gouvernement
merci beaucoup marion becker marion
depuis l'ain depuis la ville d'oyonnax
catherine tricot on va se projeter là
dans la semaine qui vient certains ont
des réserves elles les républicains vont
sans doute se reporter sur la coalition
macron pas tous mais une partie d'entre
eux d'autant que christian jacob a très
clairement appelé à ne pas voter pour
marine le pen et ses députés ces
candidats pardonnez moi que doit dire
jean luc mélenchon selon vous pour
arriver à mobiliser les abstentionnistes
donc je pense qu'il va continuer à dire
et à parler avec les autres chefs de
parti de la gauche c'est à dire qu'il va
quand même s'attacher à montrer un
rassemblement est précisément à ne pas
se laisser corner risée dans l'extrême
gauche et montrer qu'il rassemble
différentes formations et il va rappeler
ce qu'il a fait ce soir entre dans sa
déclaration c'est à dire qu'est ce que
la nuque propose et sa s'oppose à quel
projet et je pense que véritablement
c'est ça que vont chercher à faire le
plus possible les candidats de la nuque
c'est à dire de dire nous nous sommes
porteurs d'un progrès social d'une
préoccupation environnementale et
démocratique qui n'est pas présente de
l'autre côté et au contraire c'est et on
l'avait l'agression sociale qui venait
avant le premier tour comment dire créer
du climat pour reprendre son terme
c'était ça peut être la polémique sur
sur la police est-ce que là il doit
rassurer pour peut-être tendre la main à
quelques à quelques électeurs de gauche
qui ne serait pas forcément tentés par
cette coalition ou au contraire
continuer écrivait moi je crois pas
qu'il écrivait
il a cherché à mobiliser notamment dans
la jeunesse et des quartiers populaires
il n'a pas cherché à cliver il a cherché
à mobiliser les siens c'est un peu
différent en termes médiatiques ça a
beaucoup kléber où c'est possible c'est
possible mais l'enjeu pour jean nutella
relais à son électorat était de parler à
son électorat de mobiliser son électorat
de dire on a une chance de gagner et je
incarne une alternative sur des
questions qui vous préoccupent
et en l'occurrence le sujet qui est
beaucoup monté c'est la question des
deux du du non respect des femmes dans
cette affaire allant viennent parler
d'anama damien abad cette jeune fille
qui interpelle emmanuel macron en disant
alors vous nous mais comme ça des des
ministres et on apprend que la police
débarque dans son lycée c'est incroyable
cette histoire la jeune fille aux
interpellés macro et on envoie la police
dans glee c'est non mais ça va pas du
tout donc il ya une question sur la
police yens questions sur la le respect
du droit le respect des femmes et donc
je pense que ces sacs qu'a voulu pointer
jean luc mélenchon il a posé avec des
termes un peu cru mais pour se faire
entendre et pour dire je ne parle je ne
cautionne pas ce qui se passe voilà la
stratégie d' emmanuel macron côté jean
luc mélenchon côté emmanuel macron à
quoi peut-on s'attendre
il y à qui faut-il parler très
clairement pour mobiliser
toujours un peu compliqué car vous êtes
en position centrale et vous essayez
d'avoir des gens qui viennent des
différents endroits pour venir conclut
et c'est difficile à faire et en même
temps c'est confortable avec la force
j'aime d'horizon ce soir est ce que le
bateau ensemble ne penche pas déjà à
droite écoutez ça y verrons bien moi je
crois que cette histoire de la deûle à
des tombes d'apothicaire internes à la
majorité présidentielle
on verra plus tard pour le moment il n'y
a pas il n'y a pas de problème de ce
côté-là je sais bien que pour certains
il ya tellement le souvenir des
frondeurs socialiste que ils ont peur de
tout germe de division mais la
démocratie c'est ça aussi c'est quand
même qu'il ya des sensibilités
différentes qu'on les arbitre qu'on les
tranchées qu'on les dépasse non ça ça me
paraît pas vraiment le problème si c'est
dans la majorité présidentielle et
qu'ils ont une majorité absolue
je crois que beaucoup de gens
dans l'europe entière rêverait d'une
situation comme celle là c'est plutôt
qu'est-ce qu'on fait qu'est-ce qu'on
donne comme indication pour le deuxième
tour lorsque
voilà il va manquer quelqu'un el harti
est ce que je sois s'adresser une
rassemblement national et ce qu'il
faudrait c'est s'adresser à la nuit
quand ils ne sont pas là pour les
inciter à se reporter plutôt vers soi
c'est ça qui est plus compliqué à faire
mais enfin je fais confiance à la au
talent politique des macros nhien pourra
vous pour inventer ça au niveau local il
très rare comment vous la voyez vous
cette stratégie pour la majorité
présidentielle dans l'antre de tout
ça va être compliqué ça va tout dépend
effectivement du président de la
république c'est lui qui peut donner
l'élan c'est lui qui peut réchauffer je
dirais un peu les coeurs et c'est lui
qui peut trouver les mots donc tout
dépend de lui il est suffisamment habile
et malin pour trouver quelque chose qui
peut aiguillonner cet électorat ce qui
est extraordinaire et je suis plan d
accord avec vous sur ce que vous dites
sur mélenchon mélenchon il ne il ne
cherche pas son électorat c'est tout à
fait nouveau pour lui tout ça mélenchon
c'était 10 % de l'opinion publique
jusqu'à présent 10 15% on a senti
d'ailleurs à ses habitants donc là c'est
nouveau il se retrouve avec un influent
de nevoy et donc c'est pareil il faut
qu'il est il a un discours qui est tout
à fait assumée qui est tout à fait ce
qu'il a dit sur la police mon avis et
c'est pas du tout j'entendais des
confrères qui disait c'est sa première
faute pendant la la la la présidentielle
la campagne présidentielle et
législatives mais pas du tout c'était
assumé au total et il sait ce qu'il fait
il veut aller chercher cet électorat
sauf que là c'est plus premier tour qui
était au rendez vous de la
présidentielle je suis un trajet très
large et qu'il continue ce fameux
électeurs il est reparti dans
l'abstention pour la législative pour
les justes at il enfin bon et c'est
pareil pour un maquereau mac rouve c'est
un électorat qui est quand même c'est
difficile à saisir 1 s'est pas
complètement la droite affronté quand
même sur les républicains c'est quand
même il suscite aussi des républicains
pas chez tous psg beaucoup les
républicains c'est très simple c'est
pour ça qu'ils ont bien du mal c'est que
c'est pas un groupe uni les républicains
vous avez des républicains qui sont
extrêmement fins qui sont des libéraux
bontin est acquis
de l'entreprise je dirais acquis pour
qui macron est un représentant tout à
fait acceptable et même tout à fait
honorable beaucoup plus que beaucoup
d'autres républicains puis vous avez des
républicains qui sont des républicains
extrêmement jacobins extrêmement
régalien je n'irai pas le plein de
mètres côté là rien en tête et c'est pas
sûr que chez eux et bien macron soit
très populaire voudrait qu'on revienne
quand même sur ce qui pourrait
ressembler à une coalition malgré tout
alors on se projette sur la presse
second tour parce que quand on regarde
les projections de pierre latry pour
ipsos sopra steria quand même cette
majorité absolue c'est le premier
scénario n'est pas qu'ils fassent et la
première hypothèse est dans la deuxième
hypothèse même si elle est acquise elle
ne se peut se faire qu'avec des alliés
modem et horizons modem et la république
en marche ne suffisent pas à atteindre
d'après nos projections la majorité
absolue edouard philippe est aux anges
ce soir oui georges bataille il ya cinq
ans à tenir
sur la dia ba c'est à dire que
il a une personne
aura dans les sondages qui tient au fait
qu'il n'a plus le pouvoir
il faut donc qu'ils eurent le moment où
ils entrent dans une conquête éventuelle
dans une stratégie de conquête du
pouvoir ça peut être que vers la fin du
mandat d' emmanuel macron et d'ici là il
y aura tellement d'eau qui sera passée
sous les ponts que c'est très difficile
à prévoir donc voilà c'est incroyable
que peser sur des arbitrages et là on
est vraiment sur les vêtements comme
structurelle mais comme la nôtre est la
lui donner
arbitre conçu le modem encore plus le
modem encore plus mais c'est normal dans
une majorité où il ya des courants ça me
paraît normal et je vais vous dire même
ça me paraît assez sain
courant avant c'est celle mg acronis
pacs rappelle pas de front des
remembrements comment comment vous
n'aviez pas entendu parler dans les
arbitrages de temps en temps du fait que
par exemple entre les plus écolos et les
plus bercy non ça existe toujours et là
ça va exister de façon encore
r4 enrico oui je pense que la première
bataille qui va s'ouvrir si emmanuel
macron réussi sa majorité même relative
haute ça va être la question des
retraites edouard philippe quand même à
un peu me emmanuel macron dans le mur
avec son affaire deux dash pivot et il
était le bras droit d'alain juppé qui
était restée raid dans ses bottes droit
dans ses bottes et qui avait donc planté
sa réforme des retraites et le catena le
mandat de jacques chirac à l'époque ce
que je veux dire par là c'est que
edouard philippe il peut peut-être être
content ce soir mais il faut aussi
qu'ils se souviennent de ses propres
errements et y ont abouti à des échecs
est ce que et je suis vous rejoins tout
à fait là ce soir emmanuel macron ne
peut pas dire qu'il a un blanc seing
pour faire 7 cette réforme des retraites
et que ça va être compliqué à mon avis
elle a fini plan tête car la treille
quelles sont les attentes des français
sur cette réforme des retraites sans
forcément regarder les sensibilités ce
qui est certain c'est que c'est pas une
réforme qui est très populaire donc ça
va être très compliqué pour emmanuel
macron d'aller contre finalement la
majorité des français où il risque
d'être peut-être poussé un petit peu par
les républicains et par la droite de sa
majorité à faire cette réforme
absolument mais ça va être pour lui
quelque chose de très délicat et c'est
pas pour rien qu'il n'en a pas parlé et
qui n'a pas évoqué le sujet pendant la
campagne
évidemment il serait art j'aimerais
qu'on se projette encore un petit peu
plus le président de la république réélu
a dit qu'il tiendrait compte des
rapports de force au parlement au soir
du second tour il y aura un remaniement
on est dans deux hypothèses une
hypothèse majorité absolue mais avec des
alliés à l'intérieur une hypothèse de
majorité relative ça veut dire des
changements profonds pourquoi pas
changer matignon où là je fais trop le
oui alors attendu soit attendre le
deuxième tour pour le moment ce qui est
intéressant c'est que
moi je me mettrai dans un contexte où il
a une majorité absolue mais avec ses
alliés avec le probable avec françois
bayrou avec edouard philippe et là c'est
intéressant de voir que effectivement
sur cette réforme qui est une réforme
importante celle des retraites
importante à leurs yeux et bien il ne
parle pas de la même ils parlent pas me
le même la même rengaine puisque je
pense que
37 ans edouard edouard philippe va
beaucoup plus loin que ne pourrait aller
macron emmanuel macron qui d'ailleurs
n'avait pas le paramétrique comme
critère de réforme au début c'était un
avant systémique qui consistait en fait
à mettre de quarante deux régimes de
retraite en un seul donc c'est un je
suis même à me poser la question compte
tenu de la nouvelle assemblée savoir si
cette réforme aura lieu un tout petit
mon roland cayrol et puis on va aller
voir clément pour d'autres résultats
juste un mot sur la traite pour dire que
moi contrairement à la plupart je crois
que c'est pas trop difficile comme sujet
à condition qu'on laisse tomber l'âge
légal de la retraite
ce que n'aime pas l'allongement de la
durée de cotisation ouais par exemple en
tout cas je crois qu'il ya un tabou là
et qu'il faut pas jouer avec ça avec les
français après tout les échecs qui ont
ils eu sur sur le changement en effet il
faudra attendre de voir les résultats du
second tour mais évidemment ça
conviendra pas matignon on vous alors on
va retourner trouver clément perreault
pour de nouveaux résultats est avoue
clément c'est parti pour une nouvelle
série de résultats et je vous propose
d'alors d'abord d'aller dans le nord
voir les résultats du ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin
39,1 % des voix il est nettement en tête
devant les skis mortreux pour la nuque
23% gérald darmanin et qui devrait sans
trop de soucis être réélu allons
maintenant dans la seine et marne voir
les résultats de frank richter le
ministre délégué au commerce extérieur
29,2 pour cent il devance de quelques
points françois lenormand pour le
rassemblement national défend cristers
semble en ballottage favorable
maintenant direction l'oise pour voir
les résultats d'eric woerth c'était un
ancien député des républicains un
personnage clé de l'assemblée il a
longtemps occupé le poste de président
de la commission des finances et il est
passé à la république en marche il
obtient 27% eric woerth il devance
audrey a vez pour le rassemblement
national avec 24,1 pour cent des voix
maintenant allons dans le pas de calais
voir pierre henri dumont candidats les
républicains et bien il est en seconde
position pierre henri dumont 27 2%
devancé par marc de florian pour le
rassemblement national
29 2% la bataille d'entre-deux-tours
risque d'être chaude allons maintenant
en moselle voir un autre républicain qui
lui fait un excellent score fabien di
filippo 45 9% il devance michel rambour
pour le rassemblement national 21 12 2%
ça devrait passer sans trop de soucis
pour fabien di filippo toujours chez les
républicains je vous propose maintenant
d'aller prendre des nouvelles de julien
deal dans l'aisne 35 9% là aussi il est
en tête devant lola puissant pour le
rassemblement national 28 6% julien dive
est donc en ballottage favorable allons
maintenant dans le loir et cher pour
voir un candidat battu guillaume
pelletier l'ancien elle est repassé chez
reconquête elle ne fait que 13 9% des
voix il est donc battu dès ce soir un
autre candidat reconquête battu dès le
premier tour ça se passe dans le
vaucluse c'est stanislas rigaud le
président de génération zemmour il était
considéré comme l'une des révélations de
la campagne présidentielle
sa suppléante je vous le rappelle était
marion maréchal 18 5% c'est une sévère
défaite pour lui ce soir merci
infiniment clément pernot pierre latry
je voudrais qu'on s'arrête un instant
sur le rassemblement national en voix
aux législatives ce parti progresse le
parti de marine le pen progresse comme
il progressait d'ailleurs en voix à la
présidentielle est ce que ces notables
on l'a dit tout à l'heure d'ailleurs
dans des régions des terres de conquête
comme comme la gironde par exemple et
est-ce qu'au fond c'est pas aussi elle
la gagnant ce soir oui je pense que
c'est vraiment une des gagnantes c'est
une ce n'est pas une surprise parce que
les intentions de vote donnait
effectivement un score à peu près comme
ça pour le rassemblement national mais
en revanche par rapport aux précédentes
élections législatives c'est un vrai
changement à la finalement peu augmenté
son score à la présidentielle par
rapport en 2017 mais là elle fait six
points de plus aux 18,2 c'est 13% contre
serrières seront donc c'est vraiment un
vrai changement il ya maintenant il ya
un vote rassemblement national y compris
aux élections législatives qui était pas
le cas lors des scrutins précédents et
ça peut lui permettre surtout d'obtenir
un groupe ce qu'elle n'a jamais eue
hormis le cas de 1986 qui était un cas
très particulier de la proportionnelle
intégrale fait à la proportionnelle
intégrale
là pour le coup celle réussie avoir un
groupe ça sera une vraie réussite et
sans oublier aussi que pour les
candidats reconquête le résultat est pas
terrible puisqu'ils récuser m'aurait
battu guillaume pelletier battu
stanislas rigaud aussi donc c'est pour
elle plutôt une soirée réussie c'est une
stratégie payante roland cayrol quand on
pense au mode de scrutin si défavorable
au rassemblement national ils peuvent
avoir 45 ans borno au député dimanche
prochain c'est incroyable parce que
ouais il dit non plus parfaitement aux
besoins de la proportionnelle bassi à
bombes ainsi parce que vous voyez bien
quelqu'un fait 41 % dans un second tour
de présidentielle sont si elles sont
c'est parce qu'il ya un bas d'une
fourchette il ya le lot
la borne
moi je les ai comptées j'arrive pas à
trouver 45 donc ils sont un peu
optimistes là nos amis dit plus haut je
mettrais bien ça veut dire quand même
que elle est la victime principale le
mode de scrutin et elle a toujours été
que le fameux plafond de verre dans ces
second tour il ya des duels donc il faut
faire comme disait mon ami la pallice à
grande pour cent et le franchissement de
cette barre de 50% elle est extrêmement
passionnel est ce qu'on pourrait
imaginer un étiage combien de députés
rassemblement national à bas beaucoup
plus en tout cas ils sentaient oui sans
avoir d'alliance comme et oui c'est ça
le problème c'est qu'il n'ya pas
d'alliance possible à part reconquête et
c'est le rassemblement national lui-même
qui a repoussé l'offre zemmourienne ils
sont ils sont quand même coincé c'est
vrai que ces deux succès en succès c'est
quand même toujours un échec annoncé
parce que le système si je ne me le
permet pas pour justement changer ce
serait mérité sept mois je crois que par
ailleurs il faut il faut le changer il
n'y a pas tant qu'il n'y a pas que pour
le rassemblement national je sais bien
que la vertu d'un système majoritaire
c'est que il dégage plus facilement des
majorités etc mais il le fait en tordant
quand même la volonté populaire et c'est
pas hasard les petits partis ou les
partis qui sont
victime de sa demande de la
proportionnelle voir l'un
proportionnelle mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est de voir la réaction
des français interrogés dans d
innombrables sondage les français sont
favorables à la proportionnelle
intégrale et ils disent qu'est ce que
vous voulez la première vertu d'une
assemblée c'est de ressembler à l'erp
aux électeurs pourquoi nos représentants
de la faune c'est bien parce qu'il faut
croire que ceux qui sont qui bénéficie
du système bénéficie suffisamment vous
savez je citais souvent à mes étudiants
ce mot attribué au général de gaulle
le meilleur mode de scrutin c'est celui
qui fait élire le maximum de vos amis
catherine frécaut oui moi je ce que je
note c'est que elle s'implante dans de
nouvelles terres et la gironde me semble
être indiqué indiqué quelque chose qui
s'est produit pendant le mandat des
manuels macro notamment avec le
mouvement de gilet jaune ce mouvement
était très incertain sur le plan
politique et que l a réussi finalement à
capter une partie de ce mouvement là qui
était puissant en gironde et je crois
que c'est ce n'est plus simplement
la france désindustrialisé c'est
vraiment la france qui se sent mise à
l'écart de la métropolisation et c'est
la france des petites classes moyennes
en rébellion contre leur déclassement et
donc elle élargit online continue
d'élargir son son socle social la
deuxième chose c'est qu'en effet le
scrutin majoritaire lui est défavorable
tant que ce maintien la digue dont je
parlais tout à l'heure c'est à dire le
front national n'est pas un parti comme
les autres parce qu'il est l'héritier
d'une histoire qui ne fait pas partie du
socle républicain est ce que je note
c'est que j'ai écouté tout à l'heure
christian jacob qui a mis également dos
à dos la nuque et emmanuel macron en
disant que finalement c'est de la non
abonnés
c'était excellent mois la nuque et le
front national en disant que c'était
deux extrêmes et que donc il fallait pas
choisir pour eux ils prenaient
exactement les mêmes voies que celles de
la majorité c'est à dire qu'en fait on
est en train en effet d'affaiblir cette
limite qui aujourd'hui constitué le
principal obstacle à l'installation de
marine le pen à l'assemblée nationale on
est en train de voir que ça va sauter
l'a compris vous l'avez dit et vous avez
bien digéré une tricot je voudrais qu'on
accorde quelques quelques minutes aux
divers gauche ça va vous intéresser
quelqu'un tricot les dissidents de la
nuque quand même c'est pas rien 4% des
voix pour les divers gauche il résiste
notamment en occitanie j'arrêterai c'est
ça c'est ce que disait martial foucault
tout à l'heure ce sont surtout des
socialistes en occitanie y résistent et
il pourrait avoir un rôle très important
dans la future assemblée nationale si
emmanuel macron n'a pas sa majorité
absolue il pourrait être un groupe
peut-être un groupe 15 avant son siège
alors oui après il ya aussi des
communistes dans l'eau ça sera peut-être
pas effectivement tous des mais il
pourrait sur certains projets s'allier
avec avec emmanuel macron et du coup ça
permettrait emmanuel macron de faire
passer certains textes que les
républicains ne voudrait pas voir et
donc à droite un coup à gauche si soro
lanta vague audi y ait un oui mais à
l'assemblée ça conforterait le leurs
proches qui leur est fait finalement de
ne pas vouloir être de gauche selon
l'amf alors que j'ai trop mal
oui c'est à dire d'aller porter main
forte à emmanuel maléon ça veut dire
qu'ils se sont posés à la nuque parce
que la nuque ne voulait pas être je vous
redonne la parole dans un instant il est
22 heures 50 et c'est avoue clément
perreault de nous livrer de nouveaux
résultats à ces législatives oui myriam
je vous propose de commencer cette série
avec la présidente du groupe socialiste
à l'assemblée nationale valérie rabault
ça se passe dans le tarn-et-garonne
première circonscription elle arrive en
tête 33 3% des voix devant le rm pierre
poma 22 4% valérie rabault en ballottage
favorable allons maintenant en savoie où
c'est un peu plus serré patrick mignola
qui lui et le président du groupe modem
et 2e 26 2% il est devancé par le
candidat du ps jean-françois colom ce ne
sera pas évident pour patrick mignola
pour l'instant en ballotage on peut le
dire défavorable c'est beaucoup plus
confortable dans le puy-de-dôme pour
andré chassaigne le président des
communistes à l'assemblée qui frôlé
l'élection dès le premier tour 49,1 %
deuxième position rigide car les taux
pour le rassemblement national avec 19%
allons maintenant voir les résultats
pour un autre président de groupe celui
du groupe parlementaire agir ensemble
c'est la droite dite constructive 40 3%
il est nettement en tête devant nadia el
hadji pour la nuque
20,3 % maintenant direction la somme
avec françois ruffin l'un des ténors de
la france insoumise 40% des voix il est
largement en tête devant nathalie
ribeiro billet pour le rn 22 5% ça
devrait passer sans trop de problème
donc pour françois ruffin prenons
maintenant des nouvelles d'un ancien
candidat à l'élection présidentielle le
communiste fabien roussel il est
candidat dans la 20e circonscription du
nord et il est en tête 34,1 pour cent il
devance d'une courte tête le candidat du
fn guillaume flore cas qui lui fait
32,6 pour cent fabien roussel donc en
ballottage favorable et pour terminer
cette série encore un président de
groupe cette fois non pas un président
de groupe ares dont le premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste
olivier faur 46 29% dans la 11e
circonscription de seine-et-marne il
devance la candidate de la majorité
présidentielle charline péculier qui
recueille 22 % des suffrages merci
clément clément pernot pour ses
résultats aux législatives
catherine tricot roland cayrol pirates
la tri et je voudrais avant de se
quitter qu'on évoque la question des
ministres en campagne on entendait les
personnalités on voit que même pour
olivier faur les choses peuvent être
compliquées pour certaines personnalités
de droite aussi elle est l rebat les
cartes quand même fait cette législative
pour les ministres certains sont plutôt
rassurés on l'a vu avec elisabeth bornes
en revanche ça n'est pas le cas par
exemple d'amélie de montchalin dans
l'essonne où jérôme guedj ancien
socialiste enfin toujours socialiste
dans la nuque excusez moi
le la devancer oui j'entends dire il y
aurait même une dizaine de points
d'écart entre eux ce qui évidemment rend
les choses extrêmement compliqué il faut
il fallait un petit peu de courage pour
aller dans ces conditions être candidat
aux législatives
d'autant qu'ils étaient prévenus ainsi
si ça marche pas ils rendent leur
tablier de ministre
les montchalin c'est que c'est une des
favorites du président de la république
a un gros portefeuille il fallait un
très gros portefeuille sur lequel il
avait en plus mis la gomme en expliquant
que c'était la transition écologique
c'était ça passait réellement par elle
évidemment on a le sentiment que sauf
une espèce de miracle entre les deux
tours il va falloir la changer les
ministres de la transition énergétique
un départ un départ d'amélie de
montchalin peut-être un clément bono 6
kg est en difficulté est ce que c'est
c'est grâce à déstabilise la macro ni et
le pouvoir ou pas tant que ça quand même
ce sont des jeunes ce sont de jeunes
talents on va dire de la macro ni et
donc je veux dire moi je pense pas
qu'ils seront des sols parce qu'en fait
il me semble que il ya aussi
l'inconvénient d'être sous les
projecteurs c'est visible l'invisible
vous avez vous pouvez cristallisé contre
vous un certain nombre de gens qui sont
très satisfaits de pouvoir accrocher au
palmarès à mini alors on garde toutes
les réserves et toute la prudence parce
qu'on attendra je suis tombé quant à lui
par exemple avait été défait à la
législative de bordeaux il avait
démissionné mais bon en 2007 le
gouvernement avait continué donc est-ce
que ça ouvre une crise non pas forcément
sinon ça n'ouvre pas de crise message
que je veux dire c'est que c'est
évidemment un signe de fragilité
parce que les jeunes
pousses de la macro ni n'ont pas tout à
fait la surface politique
peut-être qu'il leur faut il faudrait
quand même qu'ils aient un peu d'autres
personnalités un peu plus qu'est-ce que
ça à dire de terreau latrille amankwah
d'expérience politique je pense il
faudra beaucoup voir le résultat du
second tour parce que si dans les
circonscriptions où on a des ministres
médiatique on voit un déplacement de
beaucoup d'électeurs soit du rn soit de
la nuque pour le candidat contre le
ministre ça voudra dire effectivement
qu'il ya une volonté de battre ou en
tout cas de vraiment envoyer un message
très clair qui est de dire que qu'ils
veulent que ensemble soit battu je pense
que ce sera très intéressant de regarder
aujourd'hui c'est encore un peu tôt pour
voir effectivement ce qui va se passer
mais il ya quand même plusieurs
ministres qui sont dans des
circonscriptions difficile aussi je
pense à brigitte bourguignon qui est
très implanté dans sa circonscription
qu'elle est un métier une
circonscription qui a voté très
fortement pour marine le pen à la
présidentielle donc certes elle est
implantée localement mais ça sera aussi
un symbole est-ce que son ancrage local
sera suffisant pour battre pour battre
un candidat est reine dans une
circonscription où pour le coup le rn
est beaucoup plus fort ce serait un
mauvais signal forcément s'il ya
beaucoup de ministres battus à là ça
devient un vrai problème politique ouais
je dirais à la fois ci en a plusieurs ça
devient un problème politique et si en
plus ça touche des gens de ses fonctions
par lh2 d'amélie de montchalin août
clément baude si ça touche des gens qui
sont vraiment de la garde rapprochée du
président de la république de ceux sur
qui compter pour l'avenir avec les
bonbonnes c'est l'europe quand même et
c'est
l'artisan essentiel et un mari un
programme européen il est en difficulté
à paris donc voilà ça dépend des
ministres et ça dépend du nombre si ça
vient toucher directement cela le
deuxième tour nous renseignera très vite
ben c'est en effet un coup à un coût un
peu dur à supporter pour le besoin de la
république c'est une question quand même
pour la république en marge d'une façon
générale il faut quand même qu'ils
arrivent à faire émerger des
personnalités et à faire monter une
nouvelle génération qui pour l'instant
jean luc mélenchon est parvenu à cela
fait remonter une nouvelle génération en
cinq ans emmanuel macron n'y est pas
parvenu serre qu'il a toujours les
anciens du parti socialiste à ses côtés
mes mails et des nouvelles la nouvelle
garde s'est pas vraiment installe et
alors il n'aura eu qu'une petite minute
ce qu'il y a personne à part lui pour
faire comme pas y aller aujourd'hui je
profite de votre expertise une dernière
minute ce soir à ce que vous dites
toujours et à trois voire quatre forces
politiques dans ce pays ou au contraire
l'assemblée nationale montrera
l'affrontement de deux blocs qui
ressuscite une bipolarisation dos au
sein de l'assemblée
on peut pas dire qu'ils aient trois
blocs puisque le rassemblement national
ne pèse pas sa valeur dans les urnes
donc évidemment au sein de l'assemblée
mais il va y avoir une vie politique
active d'abord parce que l'ensemble luxe
va présence va représenter quelque chose
d'important ils vont pouvoir faire du
bruit et puis parce que à l'intérieur
même de la nuit pss il y aura des
groupes parlementaires est différent et
là on peut que faire en verra en plus
qu'il avait eu la nuit sera durable ou
pas peut faire confiance aux partis de
gauche pour eux avoir une certaine
vigueur on n'aime pas ça demandera un
autre débat merci merci infiniment
d'être venu en direct commenté ces
élections législatives ce premier tour
je vous rappelle les rapports de force
peut être est ce qu'on a le temps
25,6 pour la nuit au coude à coude avec
ensemble
25,2 vous le voyez 19,1 le rn les
républicains 13,6 reconquête 4% 4,1 vous
allez rester avec nous maintenant parce
que la soirée électorale continue sur
lcp en partenariat avec france info
antenne commune jusqu'à minuit avec
brigitte boucher louis laforge qui vont
prendre la main dans un instant merci
infiniment à toutes les équipes de la
chaîne parlementaire qui n'ont pas
ménagé leurs efforts pour cette soirée
électorale
[Musique]
et cette soirée se poursuit sur france
info canal 27 mais aussi sur l'antenne
de lcp sur le canal 13 de la tnt une fin
de soirée que nous partageons donc avec
nos confrères de la chaîne parlementaire
et on en est ravi bon enfin monsieur
bonsoir louis laforge en effet très
heureuse de vous retrouver pour cette
émission commune à nos deux rédactions
durant laquelle nous allons bien sûr
revenir sur les principaux résultats et
les enseignements de ce premier tour des
élections législatives et grâce à nos
deux chaînes et bien nous sommes
présents un peu partout en france dans
les circonscriptions clés du territoire
vous allez également entendre les
principales déclarations des
responsables politiques ce soir et pour
tous les résultats circonscription par
circonscription les rapports de force au
niveau national et la projections en
terme de sièges notre partenaire ipsos
sopra steria nous accompagne pour ces
législatives avec des estimations qui
sont affinés tout au long de cette
soirée est avec nous sur ce plateau pour
réagir aux résultats de la soirée se
projetait sur le second tour dimanche
prochain nous sommes ravis d'accueillir
paul midy bonsoir bonsoir être directeur
général de la république en marche qui
s'appelle toujours la république en
marche le nom changera cet été pour
renaissance vous êtes le candidat de la
majorité présidentielle dans la 5e
circonscription de l'essonne thierry
mariani bonsoir soit député européen
vous représentez donc ce soir le
rassemblement national
manon aubry a pour la nuque va nous
rejoindre dans quelques minutes alors
lui avant de commencer ce débat avec nos
invités politiques nous vous proposons
de découvrir la projection de la future
assemblée nationale en termes de sièges
des estimations qui nous sont fournies
par notre partenaire ipsos oprah steria
ce soit alors cette projection interne
de sièges elle donne pour ensemble le la
coalition présidentielle entre 255 et
285 de 195 sièges pour la nuque
l'alliance de l'ensemble de la gauche
entre 150 et 190 sièges pour lr udi et
divers droite entre 50 et 80 sièges pour
l'heure le mans nationale 20 à 45 sièges
les divers gauche entre 15 et 25 sièges
autres 10 à 17 sièges et puis nous avons
également le détail par bloc avec deux
grands ensembles qui se dégage ce soit
pour ensemble la république en marche
obtiendrait entre 189 et 219 sièges le
modem entre 45 et 55 sièges horizon
entre 21 et 26 sièges et là on voit les
estimations pourcentage pour chaque
groupe 25 6% pour la nuque qui
arriverait donc on est selon les
estimation d'ipsos
25,2 pour ensemble la majorité
présidentielle 19,1 pour le
rassemblement national pour la droite
les républicains et ses alliés 13,6 et
4,1 pour cent pour reconquête
aucun candidat reconquête qualifié pour
le second tour eric zemmour est lui-même
battu
paul midy c'est une défaite pour la
majorité présidentielle ce soir même si
en terme de sièges selon ces projections
vous arrivé en tête en termes de
pourcentage vous êtes deux battus en
deuxième position derrière la nuque oui
je crois qu'il faut faire attention à
pas reprendre les éléments de langage de
monsieur mélenchon qui se croient que
j'ai réfléchi pour moi je reprends pas
les éléments de langage de jean-luc
mélenchon oui les chiffres sont là bas
vous voyez les chiffres 1 et ça reste
encore plus des estimations on est au
touche touche par contre je pense que ce
qui est important ce qui effectivement
on est au premier tour donc il faut
entendre les messages que les électeurs
nous passent et entendent voilà les
diverses sensibilités
voilà qui se sont exprimés et vous dans
votre circonscription par exemple et
qu'est-ce qui vous disent vos électeurs
alors c'est difficile de vous dire parce
que les scores sont pas encore là ça n'a
pas atterri je vois la croiser deux
doigts mais a priori je remercie les
électeurs qui me place au second tour
mais cédric villani ou plus face à
cédric villani ce qui arriverait en tête
de ce premier tour a confirmé mais en
tout cas voilà cédric villani c'est le
candidat de monsieur mélenchon et moi je
veux quand même bien clarifiée il faut
se battre projet contre projet monsieur
mélenchon c'est la sortie de l'europe
c'est la sortie de l'otan c'est la
complaisance avec vladimir poutine s'est
quand même quand on regarde ses
résultats dans le détail en nombre de
sièges 255 à 2 195 sièges vous êtes
possiblement avec une majorité relative
et non plus absolu que vous aviez vous
seule la république en marche en 2017
est ce que c'est pas un sérieux
avertissement que vous ont lancé les
électeurs ce soir oui avertissements
peut-être avec l' envie d'avoir une
opposition à l'assemblée nationale mais
là je pense que le sujet est claire mais
il faut pas confondre à nouveau les
résultats de premier et de second tour
on n'est pas encore au second tour et
moi j'appelle tous les électeurs qui
veut qu'ils veulent éviter le blocage du
pays que nous promet monsieur mélenchon
à donner de la force au candidat de
l'ensemble de la majorité présidentielle
pour que évidemment c'est score soit
plus important est qu'on ait une vraie
majorité à l'assemblée nationale alors
maintenant voyez vous répondra dans
quelques minutes quand elle arrivera sur
ce plateau pour la nuque en attendant
thierry mariani le rassemblement
national selon ces projections de notre
partenaire ipsos auprès steria serait
crédité de 20 à 45 sièges dans la future
assemblée largement de quoi constituer
un groupe parlementaire
c'est un bon résultat vous espériez
davantage encore oui on espérait
davantage mais bon c'est un bon résultat
pour quoi d'abord parce que pour la
première fois le score de marine le pen
aux élections présidentielles se
retrouve à quelques points malgré quatre
points très grave oui une habitude ces
dix points près si ma mémoire est bonne
la dernière fois on sait le score
s'était effondrée et donc à 10 9% on
retrouve quand c'était 13 % en 2017
voilà donc le score quand se maintient
deuxièmement en réalité on représente un
électeur sur cinq 19% simplement les
règles de la du scrutin majoritaire
fonds qu'effectivement on aura 40 ou 50
des buts et bien sûr que en espère plus
on verra au second tour vous savez au
second tour n'a on attend encore un
certain nombre d'informations il
semblerait qu'il ait une centaine de
duels nubes
rassemblement national par exemple à
avignon dans mon département ce sera
intéressant de voir ce qui va se passer
voilà vous craignez un barrage un
barrage face au rassemblement national
écoutez souvent la notion de barrage
c'est l'ultime argument politique c'est
ce qu'a dit christian jacob ce soir le
le patron des républicains pas une voix
au rassemblement national pour le second
tour des élections législatives
christian jacob est un peu en perdition
avec son parti ferait mieux de s'occuper
voilà et puis le barrage le barrage vous
savez quand j'entends qualifié connaît
d'extrêmes droite ça me fait toujours
sourire
je vous rappelle quand même que plus de
40% en voter pour marine le pen ya pas
40% de fachos en france voilà donc c'est
un argument j'allais dire commercial
pour préserver le pré carré après quand
j'entends explique quand j'entends dire
que la nuque le nu baisse par n'aura
gagné soyons sérieux deux minutes nuit
mais ça n'existera plus le lendemain du
deuxième
votre objectif qui était de réunir 150
députés à l'assemblée nationale on est
très très loin dans les projections à 20
et entre 20 et 45 sièges
on est effectivement j'allais dire dans
l'est dans la fourchette de ce qu'on
attendait en termes de voix est déçu en
termes de sièges parce que parce que le
scrutin majoritaire nous nous nous évite
nous écartons un certain nombre de
circonscriptions paul midy au deuxième
tour quelles consignes de vote donnent
la majorité présidentielle a ou et bien
ensemble n'est pas représenté dans un
duel entre la nuque et le rassemblement
national vous faites quoi écoutez il
faut voir au cas par cas mais je veux
quand même rappeler le contexte nous il
a fallu qu'on gagne cette élection
présidentielle face à l'extrême droite
peut-être que ça embête monsieur mariani
mais c'est l'extrême droite voilà c'est
un programme d'extrême droite et le
combat a été difficile on l'a vu rien
n'était gagné on a réussi maintenant 50%
de français qui sont des gros fachos pas
du tout alors il ya 40 ans en france et
que l'on l'extrême droite ce que je
pense que dans ces 40% il y avait des
gens qui voulaient voter contre monsieur
mac os cambier volts et ça c'est pas ça
vous nous décrivez passé en réalité vous
employer ce mot pour décrier ça fait des
années que vous servez d'extrême droite
extrême droite comme une sorte de tabou
non mais il ya aujourd'hui guérie ans et
qui sont des patriotes et qui domine le
pen a su ménager satrio résidait assumez
vous êtes sur le spectre politique ce
qu'on appelle communément l'extrême
droite écoutez donc on est comme des
cons on va pas refaire le débat de dieu
je voulais vous n'êtes pas d'accord si
vous êtes allé excusez-moi cessieu macro
moi je suis allé avec madame le pen je
suis très content ben moi j'ai été
fidèle à mes valeurs
une différence palois vie entre
l'extrême droite et cette alliance de
toute la gauche je reste générique au
cas par cas on pourra dire qu'ils sont
prêts à s'allier avec monsieur mélenchon
alors je réaffirme mon propos ça vous
dérange pas que je me dise de trois mots
j'étais en train de dire le premier
l'élection présidentielle un nul à
gagner contre l'extrême droite c'est un
combat difficile là on est face à
l'extrême gauche parce que le petit
sourire las nubes
vous la qualifiez d'union de la gauche
cette union d'extrême gauche et vous
voyez d'ailleurs dans les chiffrages que
vous faites aujourd'hui parti socialiste
manière les enterrements la routine
extrême gauche le ps écrasante non mais
regardez les chiffres que vous prévoyez
au st denis pesce en terme de députés
mal d'une façon écrasante ce sont des
députés et les filles alors pourquoi
dites vous qu au cas par cas vous
pourriez soutenir la nuque non je ne dis
au cas par cas il faut regarder chacune
des circonscriptions en fonction des
personnalités et c'est un travail que
nous ferons dans les prochains jours
allez on va écouter la première ministre
elisabeth bande qui tire les
enseignements de ce premier tour et
malgré des résultats décevants pour la
majorité la chef du gouvernement se veut
optimiste en vue du deuxième tour
ce soir des millions de français ont
choisi des candidats de la majorité
présidentielle
grâce à eux et à notre présence massive
au second tour nous sommes la seule
force politique en mesure d'obtenir la
majorité à l'assemblée nationale face à
la situation du monde et à la guerre aux
portes de l'europe nous ne pouvons pas
prendre le risque de l'instabilité et
des approximations
face aux extrêmes nous seuls portons un
projet de cohérence de clarté et de
responsabilité et nous allons tout de
suite partir dans la circonscription
d'elisabeth bornes dans le calvados à
vire elisabeth bande qui a réalisé qui
arrive en tête avec plus de 30% des voix
hélène bonduelle vous êtes sur place la
première ministre qui est en bonne
position pour l'emporter au second tour
oui en tout cas qui s'est qualifiée vous
l'avez dit avec 34% des voix elle
affrontera un adversaire un jeune
candidat de 22 ans de la nuque qui est
arrivé avec la 24% des voix le candidat
rassemblement national lui est éliminée
alors qu'il avait atteint le second tour
il est à 5 ans alors visiblement n'était
pas là effectivement mais ces militants
son qg de campagne et son suppléant
freddy certains est venu se féliciter de
cette qualification au second tour
devant la presse tout à l'heure il faut
dire que elisabeth bornes jouer gros
vous le savez parce que en cas d'échec à
ces élections et bien la première
ministre peut tout simplement perdre son
poste à matignon pour celle qui se
présentait pour la première fois à une
élection devant des électeurs elisabeth
bornes qui était à paris mais qui rentre
ce soir très tard à vire parce qu'elle
commet cette campagne pour le second
tour dès demain matin toute la journée
elle sera sur le terrain dans sa
circonscription à une vingtaine de
kilomètres d'ici hélène bonduelle pour
lcp et france info merci manon aubry
nous a rejoints bonsoir bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous et eurodéputé la france
insoumise et ce soir vous représentez la
nuque la nuque qui a gagné ce premier
tour oui je crois que c'est une belle
victoire aujourd'hui nous sortons en
tête de ce premier tour de l'élection
législative alors que nous avons
quelques quelques semaines d'existence
nous sommes en capacité d'être second
tour dans j'espère en moins 400
circonscription alors que si on agrégé
nos scores en 2017 nous étions au second
tour que dans 170 circonscriptions ça
donne lieu de la progression et puis les
temps forts pourcentages de voix c'est
pas en projections de sièges dans la
salle moratoire en tête en termes de
pourcentage de voix ce qui veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui le bloc si on parle de
blogs politiques qui a le plus fort
soutien dans le pays au premier tour de
l'élection législative c'est bien la
nuque et ça veut dire aussi quelque
chose de la soif de justice sociale de
justice écologique et même au delà des
bons résultats je peux vous l'annoncer à
l'heure où je vous parle on a déjà
plusieurs candidats qui ont été élus au
premier tour ce qui
dit quelque chose aussi de la dynamique
alexis corbière à montreuil sarah le
grain dans 19 e arrondissement de paris
danièle obono dans le xviiie
arrondissement de paris et ça veut dire
qu'il ya une forte mobilisation puisque
ils ont fait bien plus mais maintenant
aubry c'est quand même un échec on a
entendu jean luc mélenchon en délire
élisez moi dès l'entre-deux tours de la
présidentielle
vous n'avez pas réussi un déchet mais
cohabitation ce soir vous êtes très loin
dans termes de sièges vous êtes au
maximum à 190 sièges dans les
estimations projections alors ça dépend
des projections certaine nous donne à
210 ou à 220 sièges cassés 289 pour
avoir la majorité absolue ça va être un
peu compliqué alors regarde re examinons
ensemble une chose en 2017 les
projections au soir du premier tour de
l'élection législative donné à la
république en marche il ya la majorité
entre 390 et 400 4 436 sièges ils en ont
eu en réalité 350 c'est à dire au moins
50 de moins que les projections qui leur
ont été donnés faisons l'exercice à
présent sur le résultat de ce soir
imaginez 50 sièges de moins que les
projections là nous tombons autour de
200 sièges pour la république en marche
et c'est encore possible oui d'avoir une
forte mobilisation luc mélenchon premier
ministre hun sen est encore possible de
vous le dis et je vais vous dire comment
c'est possible comment c'est possible je
sais pas si on va y arriver j'ai pas de
boule de cristal ça tombe bien il ya une
campagne pour le second tour des
élections législatives je suis content
de vous mais évidemment mais comment
qu'est ce qui va faire la différence
pour nous c'est si tous les jeunes tous
les personnes des quartiers populaires
qui sont fortement mobilisés pour jean
luc mélenchon lors du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle si leur
viennent de voter pour ce second tour et
qu'on a un surplus de mobilisation alors
oui je veux dire à tous ces gens là
croyez si c'est possible on n'a jamais
vu un président dans l'histoire de la
vème république avec l'inversement du
calendrier électoral qui fait un si
faible score parce que le projet de
maquereaux n'est pas majoré pelles à la
mobilisation de votre côté c'est le cas
aussi pour marine le pen tout à l'heure
on l'a entendu pour le président de la
république elisabeth bornes paul midy
qu'est ce que vous répondez à manon
aubry non je pense qu'il faut vraiment
vous fassiez attention d'avoir en tête
qui a effectivement un deuxième tour
dans cette élection est donc une semaine
de campagne parce que quand on vous
encore organisons un débat l'impression
jean luc mélenchon je vous ai laissé
parler si vous pouvez me donner 30
secondes pour finalement ce sera super
vous vous exprimez comme si vous aviez
gagné cette élection
ok les estimations vous donne peut-être
0 5% au dessus de notre estimation de
premier tour mais regardez il faut
toujours faire attention aux estimations
j'ai regardé en nombre de sièges en gros
c'est 100 sièges de plus pour la
majorité présidentielle donc il faut pas
inverser non plus ce qui se passe mais
l'élection donc la paix aux objections
en termes de sièges c'est pour ça qu'il
faut à la tête froide nous ne sommes
dans une posture d'humilité nous allons
faire campagne à fond pendant cette
semaine pour aller arracher une majorité
pour pouvoir gouverner le pays alors il
y avait jean et le quinquennat précédent
avec une majorité relative et imaginer
qu est ce que ça va être la gestion du
pays avec l'ordre mondial dans lequel
nous sommes s'il n'y a pas une majorité
claire pour le président alors là on
parlait de destination de projection
soir d'élection c'est aussi les
résultats qui compte 15 ministres et qui
sont en lice pour ces législatives
certains en situation délicate à l'issue
de ce premier tour on rappelle la règle
édictée par emmanuel macron chaque
ministre battu dans sa circonscription
devra démissionner feront goûter quels
sont les résultats de ces candidats
ministre a bien écouté louis d'après les
premiers résultats qui nous
appartiennent aucun des ministres ans ne
semble en situation délicate on va tout
de suite filet dans les hauts de france
dans le département du nord si le visuel
veut bien s'afficher pour voir la
circonscription de gérald darmanin
lemine dans brigitte bourguignon pardon
on recommence parle pas de calais arrive
largement enfin elle arrive en tête 1
32% et elle a un deuxième tour face à
une candidate du rassemblement national
mais elle devrait pourquoi pas bénéficié
du report de voix de la candidate de la
droite dans cette sixième
circonscription attention à ces une
circonscription où au premier tour la
présidentielle marine le pen a fait plus
de 30 % des suffrages toujours dans les
hauts de france le nord gérald darmanin
ballottage très favorable près de 40%
des suffrages pour le ministre de
l'intérieur qui affrontera une candidate
de la france insoumise au second tour
leslie mortreux on continue avec les
membres du gouvernement je voulais dit
ne sont a priori pas menacé avec des
ballottages plutôt favorable on va
partir du côté je crois du loir et cher
voilà marc fesneau le ministre modem de
l'agriculture 32% au premier tour
ballottage favorable a encore face à un
candidat elle est fille ce sera reda
belkadi le candidat et rennes est
éliminé de peu et puis on enchaîne
encore avec un nouveau membre du
gouvernement olivier dussopt le ministre
du travail 30 % on est dans l'ardèche la
seconde circonscription là aussi
ballottage plutôt favorable face au
candidat elle est fille christophe goût
nous elle encore un résultat en ce qui
concerne le gouvernement c'est franck
riester le ministre délégué au commerce
extérieur qui là aussi un ballottage a
priori favorable 20 un peu moins de 30%
des voix face à un candidat est reine et
jeu terminant je terminerai en vous
disant qu'on n'a pas le visuel mais a
priori ballottage très favorable pour
olivier avérant ministre des relations
avec le parlement on attend aussi
surtout l'île de france où beaucoup de
ministres se présente mais pour
l'instant vous le voyez la carte et
vierge les résultats ne nous sont pas
encore parvenus
et dans les circonscriptions de
plusieurs ministres il en manque un
c'est damien abad le ministre des
solidarités de l'autonomie et des
personnes handicapées qui arrive en tête
ce soir avec
33,3 pour cent des voix nous partons
d'ailleurs tout de suite à oyonnax dans
la 5e circonscription de liens où se
trouve marion becker marion le ministre
est en ballottage favorable en dépit des
affaires qui ont empoisonné la campagne
effectivement brigitte ici visiblement
les accusations de viol à l'encontre du
ministre damien abad n'ont pas pesé sur
cette campagne il est en ballotage vous
l'avez dit très favorable avec plus de
33 % des voix au premier tour devant la
candidate de la france est soumise de
l'alliance des gauches florence pisani
qui recueille un peu plus de 23% des
bois vient ensuite le rassemblement
national avec 19% et les républicains
avec
10% des voix des records qui pourraient
bénéficier justement faveur de damien
abad pour ce second tour il est apparu
ici en mairie d'oyonnax vers 20h30
visiblement très soulagé par ces
résultats il est venu saluer et
remercier ses partisans qui étaient ici
et qu'ils ont accueilli très
chaleureusement
il les a vraiment véritablement
remercier il a appelé à la mobilisation
pour le second tour pour éviter une
nouvelle abstention forte ici car
l'enjeu bien sûr pour damien abad comme
pour tous les ministres c'est de ne pas
perdre ce second tour sinon il devra
quitter le gouvernement
merci beaucoup marion becker depuis
oyonnax
man aubry avant votre arrivée on
commençait à se projeter sur le second
tour et a parlé des consignes de vote
dès des reports de voix vous avez deux
opposants politiques face à vous en cas
d'affrontement entre ensemble et le
rassemblement national au second tour ce
ne sera pas la majorité des cas mais ça
sera le cas dans certaines
circonscriptions où vous faites quoi la
nuit
demandez à vos électeurs de se
positionner comment les choses sont très
claires et seront les mêmes que lors du
second tour de l'élection présidentielle
c'est que pas une seule voix ne devra
aller à l'extrême droite et vous le
savez comme moi pour certains électeurs
ils arriveront à voter pour le candidat
de la république en marché pour d'autres
ce sera difficile parce qu'ils les
portent à juste titre responsable des
politiques anti sociales de ces
dernières années j'observe que la même
clarté
n'est pas réciproque du côté de la
république en marche il ya aussi un
certain nombre de duels qui vont opposer
le rassemblement national et des
candidats de la nuque j'ai été sur
d'autres plateaux télé ces dernières
heures face à des députés ou même
ministre de la république en marche qui
n'était pas clair sur quels seraient
leurs attitudes sont ils prêts à faire
barrage à l'extrême droite ou non et
j'ai senti un certain malaise entre un
candidat de la nuque et un candidat de
l'extrême droite et c'est vrai que c'est
une question qui est intéressante à se
poser on n'a pas le nombre total de
circonscription pour lesquelles ça se
pose mais de fait ça va se poser quand
même pour un certain nombre de
circonscriptions donc c'est aussi une
question que j'ai ici alors à l'égard de
la république vous allez avoir la
réponse de paul midy paul midy alors non
mais d'abord il faut quand même
clarifier que ça sera a priori dans un
très petit nombre de grilles mis le
canon mais ça je sais que ça intéresse
centaine jeu jj je n'y crois pas mais
dizaine cette position mais sur le
principe centaines et qu'il y en ait de
10 11 et 10 avant que maintenant brille
arrive l a pas entendu votre réponse au
cas par cas et on étudiera à la
situation locale mais j'aimerais bien
compris les critères en fait alors
pareil j'ai essayé de continuer si vous
me laissez parler vos interlocuteurs
vous laisser seuls parce que vraiment
comme vous faites un beau duo à je te
donne mais vois tu prends les mets voix
non mais si
le même scénario que les présidentielles
vous avez servi de marchepied à monsieur
mac rang oui bien sûr l extrême droite
qui veut tout comme la république en
marche ne pas augmenter le salaire
minimum le smic nous savons quel camp
nous sommes mais comme la réponse
m'intéresse
merci de ces un peu parlé non je pense
qu'on va regarder au cas par cas vous
savez des choses très différentes dans
la nuque s il peut y avoir des candidats
qui viennent du ps une gauche de
gouvernement et plus des candidats
d'extrême gauche venant de l efi
évidemment il faudra regarder au cas par
cas voilà c'est ça notre essai avec vous
on est d'accord sur le même programme
que aujourd'hui si un électeur va voter
pour un candidat de la nuque que ce soit
un candidat qui issu du parti socialiste
rue de la france un sou mise nous
partageons un programme de 650
proposition la retraite à 60 ans le
blocage des prix des produits de
première nécessité que les gens soient
d'accord ou non avec ses propositions en
tout cas c'est le programme qui est
proposée par la nuit plein mais dans ce
cas là soyons clairs on a un programme
ou ceux qui soutiennent un programme
d'extrême gauche qui est celui de
monsieur mélenchon sortie de l'europe de
sortie de l'otan
qu'elle pas de hausse des impôts ni
style pour les casseurs c'est évidemment
pour on peut vous voyez vous voyez
pourquoi le débat politique a été
difficile et je pense qu'on a aussi du
mal à mobiliser les électeurs que on a
suffisamment de désaccord entre nous
pour que vous n'ayez pas à caricaturer
l'opposition non mais je crois pas je
n'ai à aucun moment j'en voulais aussi
édifier et bien je
voyais des filles dans quel document
programmatique de la nuque vous trouvez
la sortie de l'union européenne à aucun
moment alors nous ne défendons la sortie
d'union en fait je veux dire c'est moi
qui les négocie c'est parti lui le
problème de monsieur mélenchon et dans
le soin de me citer la mairie fait que
très clair c'est la même idée les pages
et des pages et jamais le temps imparti
unis ni la terre et héroïne jamais
évidemment le grand
la sortie l'union européenne quelque
choses soient très claires donc arrêter
de caricaturer nos positions si vous
voulez en débattre sur le fond qu'on
vous explique pourquoi il ya certaines
règles européennes comme les 3% de
déficit que vous voulez suivre
aveuglément et au nom desquels vous
allez à la réduire en temps de 9
milliards d'euros important et sans dire
comment le sia qui vous allez prendre
ses 80 milliards d'euros me dit est ce
que vous pouvez vous nous préciser ce
cas par cas est ce que ça veut dire que
vous fait barrage aux à la france
insoumise mais que vous acceptez
éventuellement de soutenir un socialiste
est ce que c'est ça votre cas par cas je
vous explique le cas par cas c'est le
cas par cas donc il regardera chacune de
ces quelques circonscriptions et on
prendra des décisions dans les prochains
jours au cas par cas allez on a vu tout
à l'heure les résultats des principaux
ministres candidats florent boutet
parler nous à présent d autres
personnalités de la majorité
présidentielle qui sollicitait les
suffrages des français ce soir l'un des
résultats choc de cette soirée bien
c'est jean michel blanquer ancien
ministre de l'éducation nationale qui
pour la majorité lrm n'arrive que
troisième dans la 4e circonscription du
loiret autrement dit il est éliminé dès
le premier tour face et bien aux
candidats du r n est à celui du parti
communiste qui eux se disputeront les
suffrages des électeurs pour le poste de
député au second tour christophe
castaner lui est en ballottage mais
délicat à priori dans sa circonscription
des alpes de haute provence 30% un peu
plus regardées il est talonné par le
candidat elle est fille allait au walter
il réalise beaucoup moins là et fait 44
% il ya cinq ans lors de l'élection de
2017 au premier tour on continue avec
une autre figure de la majorité en
délicatesse patrick mignola le président
du groupe modem à l'assemblée nationale
regarder ballottage défavorable
en ce qui le concerne en savoie face aux
candidats et les filles jean françois
coux l'homme et puis il ya quand même
des figures qui s'en sortent mieux
regarder richard ferrand le président
sortant de l'assemblée nationale qui lui
semble en ballotage a priori favorable
il devance la candidate du parti
socialiste mélanie tome 1 dans sa
circonscription du finistère
on enchaîne avec
regardez dans la somme barbara pompili
qui elle est au touche touche avec mais
elle arrive deuxième avec la candidate
elle fit zahia hamdane elle pourrait
peut-être pourquoi pas quand même
bénéficié du report de voix de l'ue dit
la candidate udi pour l'emporter qui
sait au second tour ça sera peut être
serré et puis dernier un résultat eric
woerth qui a changé d'étiquette il était
l air il est devenu lrm 27% il est en
ballotage face à une candidate du rn
regarder ce qui est intéressant c'est
que au niveau national la couleur ici en
violet de la majorité et bien par
rapport au résultat qui nous parviennent
eh bien elle est beaucoup moins
écrasante qui lie à cinq ans ou au
premier tour la quasi totalité de la
france avait placé un candidat en marche
en tête ici même si cette année il nous
manque les résultats des grandes villes
ou des résultats pourrait être plus
favorable à la majorité et bien on voit
que c'est beaucoup plus parcellaire en
ce qui concerne les couleurs merci
laurent boutet thierry mariani quand
vous entendez le débat sur ce plateau
pas une voie pour le rassemblement
national c'est aussi ce que disent les
principaux responsables politiques de
chaque partie ce soir est ce que vous
êtes inquiet d'un tir de barrage pour le
second tour on est un peu habitué on est
un peu habitué parce que cet argument ça
reste depuis je vais dire vingt ans la
tarte à la crème permanente et moi j'ai
quand même assisté à une discution
discussions touchante entre vous deux
que tout oppose que tout oppose sauf
peut-être effectivement
je suis d'accord avec vous
une chose c'est que vous repasser les
plats
l'essentiel étant finalement que
d'arriver à faire battre les candidats à
patriote et je pense que cette séquence
était assez parlante voilà après
j'attends de voir avec
j'allais dire plaisir comment vous allez
trancher au cas par cas ce qui est sûr
c'est que
l efi monsieur mélenchon fait à nouveau
avec en marche une partie de chemin en
commun et puis ce qui est sûr aussi
c'est que la du ps n'existera plus
soyons sérieux deux minutes vous
raconter comment
vous raconter un conte de fées on a
d'abord eu mélenchon premier ministre
vous savez très bien comme moi qui vous
serez à l'assemblée nationale il ya un
groupe socialiste il y aura un groupe
elle est ce que ce n'est pas une
alliance
cc on est prêt à parier qu'il y aura
plusieurs groupes madame aubry alors
vous avez bien lu l'accord politique qui
est le nôtre oui il y aura plusieurs
groupes qui vont travailler ensemble sur
un programme commun et donc on est
aujourd'hui la seule formation politique
qui se présente pour cette élection
législative avec un programme fort de
650 propositions je n'ai pas bien vu
qu'elle était le programme de deux
ensembles seul du clergé produit j'étais
votre programme aussi à si vous avez
vous allez voir c'est spécifié donc je
me ferai un plaisir de vous l'offrir à
la sortie parties communes il y a trente
deux nuances sur lesquels oui nous
allons laisser l'assemblée nationale
discuter entre elles et se mettre
d'accord parce que on croît de manière
assez faibles ou pouvoir ne m'en fera t
il quand même dans une à lyon sujet à
une alliance oha lots datant de l'europe
l'europe je vous renvoie au chapitre sur
l'europe que manifestement personnes
élus autour de cette table même sur le
boulevard dont ils avaient mon âge
totalement la jeune fille je vous le dis
vous étiez dans la salle des
négociations
non mais donc cher est le 19e donc je
vous le dis et je vous mets au défi de
trouver par ailleurs des désaccords sur
la manière dont on parle de ce chapitre
sur les questions européennes et c'est
d'ailleurs ça qui fait la force
aujourd'hui de la nuque c'est
précisément d'avoir un accord non pas
électoraliste non pas sur un coin de
table n'ont pas de distribution des
circonscriptions qui a un accord
politique pour changer la vie des gens
parce que la raison pour laquelle on
s'est regroupé c'est de se dire
aujourd'hui on n'est pas condamné à
avoir encore 50 plus d' emmanuel macron
on peut si on obtient une majorité à
l'assemblée nationale faire la retraite
à 60 ans faire le smic à 1500 euros nets
investir massivement dans les hôpitaux
dont on voit bien que partout dans le
pays les urgences sont en train eux
d'exposer on peut faire de la
planification écologique pour enfin
envisager notre avenir et ne pas être
condamnée à sécheresse après sécheresse
comme c'est le cas à l'heure actuelle
voilà pourquoi nous avons fait 7 7 nuls
et vous voyez c'est du contenu politique
et c'est sur ça que nous devons débattre
dans la semaine qui vient pour essayer
de mobiliser largement et que les gens à
la fin tranche entre eux je crois
essentiellement puisque la majorité des
circonscriptions ça va on peut opposer
un député ou un candidat de l'ensemble
est un candidat de la nuit et dans la
majorité de ces circonscriptions le
débat qui est posée pour
le second tour c'est retraite à 63 65
ans etc voulait bien compris c'est un
vrai débat intéressant avant de répondre
dans un tout petit instant je vous
propose à présent qu'on a eu dans la
rédaction d'el cp dans le studio où se
trouve clément perreault au coeur de
l'assemblée nationale clément vous
pouvez nous donner les estimations à des
projections en terme de sièges de
l'assemblée nationale est sans doute le
détail de ces deux grandes forces
politiques
exactement brigitte vous propose nous
sommes ici dans le studio donc bcp à
l'assemblée nationale et je vous propose
est bien de découvrir l'hémicycle en
réalité augmentée juste à mes pieds
voilà c'est une projection de ce que
pourrait être l'hémicycle dans une
semaine après les résultats définitifs
de ces élections cette projection elle
est basée sur les estimations de notre
partenaire ipsos alors le plus gros
groupe que vous voyez devant - il
apparaît en violet c'est le groupe
ensemble 255 à 295 députés pour rappel
le groupe majoritaire à l'assemblée
jusqu'ici avait 3 146 sièges c'est donc
une érosion pour la majorité
présidentielle
je vous rappelle que la barre est à 289
sièges pour avoir une majorité absolue
c'est loin d'être certain ce soir pour
les députés macro nist allons maintenant
voir le deuxième groupe il est à gauche
de l'hémicycle il est en rouge c'est la
nuque 150 à 190 députés ce sera sans
doute insuffisant pour former une
majorité absolue mais c'est une belle
progression jusqu'ici le bloc de gauche
à l'assemblée pesait 60 députés
maintenant allons voir à droite en bleu
les résultats des républicains et de
lune et y 50 à 80 sièges là aussi c'est
une érosion il avait jusqu'ici 119
sièges enfin un nouveau groupe fait son
apparition il est en bleu foncé presque
noir à droite de l'hémicycle c'est le
rassemblement national qui aurait un
groupe de vingt à quarante cinq députés
maintenant je vous propose de nous
plonger dans ce groupe ensemble ce
groupe violet qui est majoritaire avec
250 à 280 15 députés selon nos
estimations la et bien c'est la
république en marche qui serait le
groupe le plus important 189 à 2 119
députés ensuite nous aurions le modem de
françois bayrou 45 à 50 députés et enfin
groupe horizon d'edouard philippe
compterait 21 à 26 députés en 5 pour
terminer plongeons-nous au coeur de la
nuque ce groupe qui aurait donc entre
150 et 190 députés là il y aurait 96 à
115 députés et les fils et la
progression la plus spectaculaire
jusqu'ici les insoumis n'étaient que 17
dans l'hémicycle ensuite on retrouve le
parti socialiste avec 24 à 29 sièges
c'est stable il était jusqu'ici 28
europe ecologie les verts auraient enfin
un groupe à l'assemblée il n'en avait
pas lors de la dernière législature 20 à
30 sièges pour les écologistes et enfin
des communistes auraient 10 à 16 sièges
dans le nouvel hémicycle
merci clément pour ces précisions et ses
projections pour le second tour je vous
proposais ça va vous intéresser manon
aubry thierry mariani blé est peut-être
déjà entendu vos chefs de file
respectifs qui se sont exprimés ce soir
marine le pen et jean luc mélenchon qui
revendique la victoire pour jean luc
mélenchon la victoire de ce premier tour
ni
la vérité que le parti présidentiel
au terme du premier tour est battu
et des faits j'appelle notre peuple
a déferlé dimanche prochain
bien sûr
pour rejeter définitivement
les projets funestes
de la majorité de monsieur macro près
circonscription qui voit au second tour
un duel entre la république en marche et
la nuque baisse javid les électeurs à ne
pas choisir entre les destructeurs d'eau
et les destructeurs d'en bas
à ne pas choisir entre ceux qui veulent
vous priver de vos droits et ceux qui
veulent vous priver de vos biens la
france n'est ni une salle de marché neil
zad
paul midy vous avez entendu votre
programme est très critiquée que ce soit
dans la bouche de jean luc mélenchon ou
dans celle de marine le pen ce programme
est ce que vous allez pas avoir des
difficultés à l'appliquer avec une
possible majorité relative vous raison
c'est tout le sujet de ce second tour il
faut que les françaises choisissent
entre
un espèce de bazar à l'assemblée
nationale où le gouvernement ne pourra
pas diriger et donner une majorité
claire au président de la république
pour qu'au moins on fasse avancer le
pays et moi j'appelle tous ceux qui
peuvent et vous qui veulent éviter ce
blocage à l'assemblée nationale qui
veulent éviter ce blocage institutionnel
qui veulent voilà donner un peu de force
à notre projet qui est seul projet de
stabilité est d'ordre que nous pouvons
proposer nous avons un projet qui est le
seul à être pro européen face à monsieur
mélenchon qui j'espère que nos
partenaires européens ne vont pas lire
le programme parce que je ne pense pas
qu'on s'en tire
bien essayé métreur deuxième élément
nous sommes le seul programme qui a la
capacité de faire la transition
écologique parce que justement va
s'appuyer sur l'union européenne et on
va s'appuyer sur le nucléaire parce que
quand on veut faire comme monsieur
mélenchon sortir du nucléaire on
est ado mais ce n'est pas gagné ce soir
et puis il pourrait y avoir tiré mariani
des alliances et éventuellement avec la
nuque dans l'hémicycle je pense au
blocage des prix des produits de
première nécessité vous êtes d'accord je
pense à la retraite entre 60 à 62 ans
vous êtes d'accord est ce qu'il pourrait
y avoir des alliances contre la majorité
présidentielle chaque fois qu'elle est
chose intelligente qui sont proposés par
un parti qui n'est pas le nôtre en les
votes madame et aubry et moi siégeant au
parlement européen je l'invite à voir le
nombre de fois où on a voté des
propositions qui venait de la part de
son groupe et qui allaient dans le bon
sens c'est pas à la règle mais voilà on
n'a jamais fait preuve de sectarisme je
crois que ce qui compte c'est l'intérêt
des français on est tous les deux par
exemple contre la retraite à 65 ans
c'est très clair à faire alliance
éventuelle mais il n'est pas question de
faire alliance rejoint pas sur la
proposition nous défendons la retraite à
60 ans qui joue là n'est pas le cas
durant quarante deux ans d'annuités
voilà ce qu'on défend marine le pen est
très claire voilà donc on s'opposera au
projet de monsieur macron là dessus et
on fera tout pour que effectivement la
casse sociale soit limitée par lancement
d'un tenant mais attendez là sujet de il
faut arrêter de parler de cas social
regardez les résultats de qena on a fait
la moitié du chemin vers le plein emploi
moi je suis né en 1983 depuis que je
suis née on est dans le chômage de masse
en france et on est enfin sur une
trajectoire où on a réduit le chômage de
2 à 3 points si on réussit à faire la
même trajectoire pendant ce quinquennat
on sera au plein emploi c'est presque
vertigineux comme exemple comme objectif
est donc ça c'est ça le projet que nous
on propose et moi j'ai porté pendant
cette campagne un sujet d'émancipation
personnel et l'émancipation personnel ça
commence déjà par être en capacité de
choisir et de trouver un emploi c'est
cette trajectoire lac ont proposé dans
je vais penser vous n'allez pas être
obligé de gauchiser un petit peu votre
discours nous le faire évoluer votre
programme j'aimerais d'ailleurs entre
les deux tours de la présidentielle
si je peux encore être excusés par
emmanuel masson sur les retraites du
tout je vous le précise
écologique nous sommes dans le
dépassement du clivage gauche droite je
crois que vous avez bien compris ce
qu'on essaye de faire avec les mails
macron depuis un peu plus de cinq ans
maintenant donc si vous voulez vous
référer à la gauche et la droite dans
notre programme il ya des mesures qu'on
peut qualifier de gauche et des mesures
qu'on peut qualifier de raciste et rien
n'a changé depuis des mois et des mois
nous avons été très clairs sur ce projet
là et on va rester sur un projet je
continue mon propos de tout à l'heure
pour améliorer le chômage pour améliorer
le pouvoir d'achat et ça sera la
première loi nous passerons à
l'assemblée nationale si nous arrivons à
avoir une majorité dans le dans la
semaine prochaine nous améliorons la
sécurité à ce que je veux rappeler quand
même que le projet de monsieur mélenchon
c'est quoi c'est pas considérer que la
police protège c'est de considérer que
la police tue on peut pas se retrouver
sur des challenges on a passé un long
moment c'est ce soir à reparler de cette
phrase de jean luc mélenchon va pas
refaire le mée patronat très
rapidement s'il vous plaît parce qu'il
faut qu'on donne d'autres résultats
c'est aussi la régie pour achever de
vous convaincre de pourquoi en parlant
de casse sociale avec le gouvernement
des manuels mâcon quel est le bilan des
manuels maquereau au bout de ces
cinquante quinquennat c'est 10 millions
de personnes qui vivent au dessus du
seuil de pauvreté ces 8 millions de
personnes qui dépendent de l'aide
alimentaire
et ça le gouvernement n'a fait que le
choix de l'accélérer et de l'aggraver
parce que pendant qu'il faisait des
cadeaux fiscaux aux plus riches comme la
suppression de l'impôt de solidarité sur
la fortune vous avez baissé de 5 euros
et les appels et oui 5 euros pour des
ménages qui sont pauvres c'est beaucoup
et surtout la première ministre actuel
elisabeth bornes elle porte le nom d'une
des réformes les plus anti social de ce
quinquennat qu'est la réforme de
l'assurance chômage qui a fait perdre
jusqu'à 40 % d'indemnités à ceux qui
sont aujourd'hui au chômage dans notre
pays et contrairement à ce que vous
pensez être chômage n'est pas un choix
des millions de gens et de chercher
traverse la rue autant qu'ils le peuvent
ne trouve pas un emploi pour autant
allez donc vous avez fait le choix d'une
politique qui est antisociale et je
crois qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes quand
même relativement sanctionné dans cet
élégant voit maintenant avec vous fera
goûter les résultats des personnalités
qui concourait sous l'étiquette nue pour
le rappelle à la france a soumis europe
ecologie les verts le ps et le pc est ce
qui est intéressant c'est que la
totalité des figures qui représente
cette alliance semble en passe d'être
réélu regarder on part dans la somme
françois ruffin ballottage très
favorable pour lui plus de 40% des voix
il fera face à une candidate du
rassemblement national pour le second
tour on enchaîne toujours dans les hauts
de france adrien 14 départements du nord
à lille plus de 50% néanmoins a priori
il fait à -2 25% des inscrits voilà
pourquoi il est contraint à un second
tour face à une candidate modem à
vanessa duhamel on verra donc ce qui se
passera dimanche prochain pour lui mais
c'est très bien parti clémentine autain
en seine saint denis plus de 46% des
suffrages là aussi à noter que ce second
tour sera particulier puisqu'elle fait
face à une dissidente communiste pour ce
second tour néanmoins vu à l'écart a
priori elle n'a pas trop de soucis à se
faire sur sa circonscription
et puis on peut aussi parler d' alexis
corbière qui lui est élu il était lui
sur la selle la seine-saint-denis aussi
sur le secteur de pantin 62% un très
très bon score pour lui qui est l'un des
bras droit de jean luc mélenchon à
l'assemblée nationale on continue avec
les autres forces de la nuque à savoir
les socialistes regarder olivier faur
ballottage extrêmement favorable à lui
aussi pour le premier secrétaire du
parti socialiste en seine-et-marne il
fera face à une candidate la raim au
second tour qui n'a obtenu que la moitié
un peu moins 1 des voix que lui a reçu
sur son nom dans le tarn-et-garonne
valérie rabault vous savez on avait
parlé d'elle pour un peut-être poste de
premier ministre bon et va le rester à
gauche et bien elle a fait 33 %
ballottage favorable face à un candidat
du rassemblement un national sur cette
première circonscription du à tarn et
garonne pour elle et puis encore une
figure à suivre en ce qui concerne la
nuque les écologistes bien sûr on en
parle julien bayou c'est le patron de ce
parti regardez dans son score plus de
quasiment 40 9% sur la 5e
circonscription parisienne il fera face
à une candidate alarm qui pour ainsi
dire devrait faire de la figuration sur
ce second tour enfin on termine avec
fabien roussel qui sur la 26 ème
circonscription du nord est en
ballottage a priori favorable face à un
candidat du rrn même s'il faudra voir
comment les électeurs qui se sont portés
sur la majorité iront se reporter à
noter cette carte qui continue de
simples aimanté avec les les candidats
arrivés en tête on voit qu'en ce qui
concerne le rouge la nuque et bien si on
compare avec le premier tour de la
présidentielle les résultats de jean luc
mélenchon on voit que eh bien c'est le
rouge qui a gagné le plus le plus en
couleurs par rapport à cette
présidentielle il y a six semaines à
nuancer c'est vrai puisque la
participation est quand même beaucoup
plus faible pour ces législatives par
rapport à l'élection vers l'elysée et
sur cette carte de france cap au sud on
retrouve à marseille claire sergent
clair pour nous parler d'une autre
figure de la nuque manuel bompard qui
est candidat dans la 4e circonscription
des bouches-du-rhône celle où jean luc
mélenchon avait été élu député en 2017
oui emmanuel bombardier temps très bonne
passe de l'emporter au second tour il a
obtenu selon des résultats provisoires
56% des voix alors comme il n'a pas 25 %
des inscrits il y aura donc un second
tour mais ça s'annonce très bien mais
pour manuel vont par l'enjeu c'est qu'il
y ait une très forte mobilisation que
les résultats soient très fort au second
tour pour dit il envoyer un signal au
reste de la france pareil à marseille
sur les sept circonscriptions à six
candidats de la nuque sont qualifiés
marseille qui comme le disait manuel
bompard va être scrutée de près
marseille qui est le fief à vous le
disiez de de jean luc mélenchon qui a
obtenu plus de 54% des voix au premier
tour il faudra donc mobiliser les
militants manuel bompard la nuque veut y
croire ils peuvent obtenir une majorité
à l'assemblée car manuel bompard le
disait souvenez vous il ya cinq ans on
nous annonçait que la majorité
présidentielle aurait 400 450 sièges et
au final ils n'ont eu que trois cent
cinquante
on
merci clair et nous partons à présent à
paris dans la quinzième circonscription
c'est le 20ème arrondissement de la
capitale la lutte d'égos aux chantres
danielle simonnet qui est la candidate
investie par la nuque et l'amiens el
harrach dissidente du parti socialiste
c'est danielle simonnet qui arrive en
tête l amont à gaza
oui les résultats ne sont pas encore
complètement définitif mais danielle
simonnet arrivera en tête avec autour de
47 % des voix lamia el harrach 17% voici
donc le match pour le second tour vous
l'avez dit cette circonscription elle
est très particulière c'est inédit
puisque la candidate de la nulle part
investie par la nuque c'est danielle
simonnet de la france insoumise mais
elle a fait passer à une candidature
dissidente d'une sociale islamiah et la
rage enfin pas tout à fait dissidente
puisque soutenue par le parti socialiste
est soutenu aussi par des grands noms un
du ps l'eau niel lionel jospin anne
hidalgo ou encore bernard cazeneuve donc
c'est le match des gauches qui sait
jouer ici et au premier tour c'est donc
la france insoumise une des composantes
de la nuque qui est arrivé très
largement en tête alors derrière nous il
ya les militants socialistes eux ils
croient qu'ils peuvent re mobiliser pour
le second tour mais ça va être très
compliqué il ya quelques secondes
c'était les militants de danielle
simonnet qui je chantais tout près de la
mairie du 20e simonet député match
retour est bien dans une semaine merci l
amont un gars va pour toutes ces
précisions manon aubry c'est une
circonscription un petit peu
particulière avec une dissidence ps qui
ne fonctionne pas mais il ya quand même
beaucoup d'endroits où les dissidences
ps accroche la nuque et il y avait quand
même à 50 d'ici danse à peu près sur 70
candidatures du ce parti socialiste il
ya au dessus de ce soir aucune
circonscription dans laquelle il y avait
un dissident qui est arrivé devant un
candidat de la nuque donc le pari réussi
dans chacune des circonscriptions de
france il y avait une candidature du
rassemblement de la gauche et des
écologistes qui non seulement ne se fait
jamais dépassé par une autre candidature
de gauche et même qui augmente notre
capacité et notre présence au second
tour puisque on l'a dit on était présent
au second tour en 2017 dont seulement
170 circonscriptions et ce soir nous
serons présents au second tour dans au
moins le double ce qui démontre de la
progression et je pense que toutes
celles et tous ceux qui pour des raisons
ou d'autres ont fait le choix de la
dissidence auront un choix assez clair à
faire comme beaucoup de citoyens pour ce
second tour l'élection présidentielle le
projet incarné par emmanuel macron de
droite libérale et de cadeaux aux plus
riches ou un projet de partage des
richesses incarné par la nuque
finalement ce choix il est d'autant plus
évident ce soir allez on a vu il ya
quelques minutes les résultats des
personnalités de gauche on va voir
florent désormais les résultats des
principales figures du rassemblement
national à commencer par un marine le
pen celle qui a été candidate pour cette
famille politique à la cent à l'élection
présidentielle regarder 54% des
suffrages résultats définitifs mais elle
n'est pas élue ballottage pourquoi parce
qu'elles ne dépassent pas le seuil des à
25 % des inscrits elle est donc
contrainte à un second tour face à une
candidate écologiste sur sa
circonscription d'hénin beaumont on
reste dans le pas de calais avec bruno
bilde une circonscription voisine le
député sortant est reine qui est en
ballotage extrêmement favorable presque
42 % des suffrages il affrontera au
second tour jérôme darras pour le parti
socialiste et puis toujours dans les
hauts de france mais dans le département
du nord cette fois ci c'est le bras
droit de marine le pen à l'assemblée
nationale sébastien chenu il avait été
aussi candidats pour les régionales
ballottage très favorable sur cette
circonscription avec plus de 44% des
suffrages il sera opposé à et bien un
représentant du parti communiste ce pour
le second tour ailleurs en france
regardez dans l'est laurent jacot belli
il pourrait emporter cette
circonscription pourquoi et bien il a
avec 35% des suffrages un peu plus une
situation favorable en vue du le
deuxième tour face à la candidate elle
est fille on verra comment les électeurs
modem et se répartiront pour et bien les
départager au second tour on va filer
dans le sud-ouest où là aussi une
circonscription pourrait tomber dans
l'escarcelle du rassemblement national
edwige diaz près de 40% en gironde elle
affrontera à véronique à à murray
attention c'est une circonscription la
crise des gilet jaune a été vécue très
vivement ça pourrait jouer sur le
résultat d'ici à la semaine prochaine
enfin direction le sud est pour vous
montrer que le rassemblement national
dans le var la 4e circonscription
élimine eric zemmour qui ne termine que
troisième
c'est fini tu donc lottiaux qui est bien
sera opposé au deuxième tour à sereine
mauborgne pour la majorité
présidentielle et si on additionne les
deux scores et bien il est possible que
ce soit un candidat d'extrême droite qui
a essayé j'ai su pour cette
circonscription à l'assemblée nationale
merci et florent thierry mariani un mot
sur l'élimination dès le premier tour
d'eric zemmour c'est une bonne nouvelle
pour vous que tu as une nouvelle logique
en présenter liot tuyaux qui était
candidat il ya cinq ans qui est implanté
eric zemmour a été parachuté dans cette
circonscription voilà c'est tout après
la bonne nouvelle pour moi c'est que
d'abord danse en huit circonscriptions
sur 577
les candidats du rassemblement national
sont en tête quand sera présent dans
plus de 200 circonscription que tous nos
sortants sont en passe d'être réélu je
dis ça parce que c'est un peu la même
chose que pour les municipales j'entends
à chaque fois qu'on nous dit comment
mythe certains oui mais à priori seront
en lice ils sont tous en voie d'être
réélu ce qui prouve que comme aux
municipales finalement même si on nous
qualifie d' extrême quand on nous et
c'est ya les français sont plutôt
satisfaits et puis vous permettrait
aussi un petit cocorico pour mon
département puisque dans le vaucluse
dans trois circonscriptions cavaillon
orange carpentras en étant tête et donc
on peut faire aussi un excellent score
dans ce département mais quand vous
voyez le succès d'union de la gauche
vous regrettez pas de ne pas avoir fait
d'union à droite vers une union faut
être deux je dirais
oui 2 ou 4 avec vos conquêtes non mais
avec eric zemmour et s'écouter je pense
que les électeurs vont faire l'union au
deuxième tour voilà après il ya des
leçons à tirer pour l'avenir une fois
que les élections seront passées je
pense qu'il faudra renouer les contacts
mais
vu ce qui s'était passé pendant les
élections c'était assez difficile allez
nous partons à présent dans l'eau a
justement une circonscription philippe
ballard le candidat du rassemblement
national arrive en tête c'est la
deuxième circonscription de l'oise marco
pommier vous êtes sur place ballottage
favorable donc
effectivement brigitte un philippe
ballard le candidat du rassemblement
national arrive largement en tête avec
près de 35% des suffrages 34 9 %
exactement il est en ballottage
favorable vous l'avez dit face à
chanelle erban la candidate de la
majorité présidentielle qui arrive en
deuxième position avec 21 5% des voix
c'est donc ce duel que les électeurs de
la 2e circonscription de l'oise devront
arbitrer tranché dimanche prochain car
tous les autres candidats sont éliminés
dès le premier tour à commencer par
agnès t-il la députée sortante investi
par les républicains elle a obtenu moins
de 9% des suffrages elle a terminé à la
quatrième place derrière la candidate de
la nuque annick prévost qui finit 3e ce
soir
merci beaucoup juste une question
thierry mariani qui sont les premiers
opposants dans cette nouvelle
l'hémicycle ce sont les députés du
rassemblement national où les députés de
la nuque et première pause ans et ceux
qui n'ont jamais fait de compromission
d'accord ou d'appels à pour voter voilà
je répète quand même me sont pas les
plus nombreux pourquoi ce ne sont pas
les plus nombreux oui mais ses plaies
plus déterminés voilà c'est tout
monsieur mélenchon a dit très clairement
qu'il appelait à ce qu' aucune voix pour
marine le pen ce qui était en quelque
sorte un appel à voter pour monsieur
macron donc il est clair que les seuls
opposants désormais dans cet hémicycle
ce seront les députés du rassemblement
national alors ils vont revendiquer ce
rôle de premier opposant on a vu ce que
ce qu'on fait député du rassemblement
national à l'assemblée nationale n'était
même pas là au moment où il été débattu
le projet si important des retraites bon
on a fait la démonstration je crois et
chacun jugera qu'avec les 17 députés que
nous avions à l'assemblée nationale nous
tenions bien la tranchée pour proposer
un autre projet de société et
aujourd'hui je me permet de corriger
votre question n'a pas l'assurance de
est-ce que d'hypothèses vous n'auriez
pas la malheureuse diable est en
capacité d'avoir une majorité absolue ce
qui lie ce qui n'est absolument pas dit
alors on se passe bien c'est je crois
qu'on a fait la démonstration la gauche
rassemblée si vous ajoutez nos
différents groupes politiques on avait à
peine une soixantaine de députés sous le
mandat précédent et je pense que avec
plusieurs centaines de députés voire
même la majorité alors là on aura la
capacité de changer véritablement la vie
des gens et d'avoir une opposition ou
une obstruction que vous allez avoir à
l'assemblée nationale on se souvient des
dix neuf mille amendements vous aviez pu
poser sur la réforme des retraites pour
bloquer la réforme des retraites qui
était un projet qui n'était pas
majoritaire médias locaux il y aura une
assemblée nationale possible et look et
savez on se battra avec tous les outils
parlementaire qui existent pour
s'opposer à la retraite à 65 ans et je
vais même au delà il ya un truc qui est
plus efficace que même faire grève pour
face à la retraite à 65 ans c'est juste
un bulletin de danube si vous le mettez
dimanche prochain dans les urnes vous
aurez même pas à faire grève dans les
mois qui viennent puisque vous aurez la
retraite à 60 ans elle est en terme de
deux chiffres eux étaient les premiers
opposants dans l'assemblée sortante les
républicains qui avaient un peu plus de
200 députés dans la précédente assemblée
ce ne sera plus le le cas dimanche
prochain les estimations prévoient une
fourchette comprise entre 50 et 80
sièges pour la droite fabien de filippo
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
député de la 4e circonscription de la
moselle vous représentez vous arriver ce
soir largement en tête dans votre
circonscription 50 à 80 sièges selon
l'estimation de notre partenaire ipsos
oprah steria vous sauver les meubles en
quelque sorte ce soit
moi je pense que suite à l'épisode lippi
speed de la présidentielle et bien nos
élus très ancrée dans les territoires
proches des gens avec des solutions
alternatives concrètes sur tous les
sujets et qui déforme de territoire et
bien se sont mieux placés que tout ce
qu'on annonçait on nous disait 30
députés seulement il ya quelques
semaines dans les sondages aujourd'hui
nous les faisons largement motifs et je
pense que la semaine prochaine on sera
beaucoup plus proche de 80 que de 50
vous serez opposé un candidat et rennes
dimanche prochain vous arrivé en tête
avec 46%
vous appeler d'autres partenaires à vous
rejoindre
moi je m'adresse simplement à mes
électeurs je suis clair sur les valeurs
que je porte dans le travail dans la
proximité ils connaissent ma capacité ma
connaissance de tous les dossiers du
territoire mon engagement à l'assemblée
sur tous les sujets et le fait que je ne
me cacherai pas dans les débats je n'ai
pas besoin de me réfugier dans d'autres
arguments on s'affrontera projet contre
projet candidat contre le candidat c'est
le débat que je veux je ne veux pas de
faux semblant fabien di filippo on voit
qu'aujourd'hui la majorité
présidentielle pourrait avoir une
majorité relative sur les estimations
que nous avons ce soir à prendre
évidemment avec des pincettes soir du
premier tour des élections législatives
est ce que vous seriez prêt et
éventuellement à bâtir une coalition un
accord de gouvernement avec la
république en marche sur certains textes
pour faire passer des réformes
je n'ai pas vocation à être le supplétif
des manuels mac rhône sa majorité en
échange de quoi que ce soit dans la
mandature précédente chez vélo la
réputation d'être un opposant du j'ai
voté 15% des textes parce que j'estimais
qu'ils aillent dans le sens de mes
valeurs ou de l'intérêt général je le
fais sans rien demander à personne je ne
prononce en mon âme et conscience sur
chaque texte en fonction d'eux des
engagements que j'ai pris lors de ma de
ma campagne c'est ça qu'on va continuer
de faits et dans ce cas ces textes
doivent pas c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
majorité eh bien il faudra tout
simplement écouter nos propositions
c'est comme ça que cela se passera mais
sur les retraites ou sur le pouvoir
d'achat vous avez des programmes qui
sont assez similaires
non je pense qu'aujourd'hui emmanuel
fond a dit trois choses différentes lors
de sa campagne sur les retraites pour
faire preuve de beaucoup de clientélisme
dans l'antre de tous nous on veut parler
de la durée de cotisation plus de queue
de l'âge de départ en retraite on veut
parler de beaucoup de choses sous forme
d'équité on veut avoir des solutions
pour des meilleures intentions mais
qu'ils soient financés cesser maintenant
de mettre tout sur le dos des
générations cultures en les finançant à
crédit on se rend compte que ça favorise
encore le phénomène l'hyper
inflationnistes en france alors il va
falloir maintenant mai de la clarté des
valeurs du pragmatisme et de la réalité
dans la manière dont on gouverne le pays
le résultat des cinq dernières années
aujourd'hui assez désastreux pour les
six mois qui viennent je pense que si
aujourd'hui des élus comme moi
obtiennent dusty bon résultat parce que
on a su être clair sur ce qu'il fallait
faire et la direction qu'il fallait
donner au pays fabien de filippo thierry
mariani à une question pour vous oui
bonsoir
vous avez eu des positions qui ont été
claires mais quand vous comptez les 80
députés est ce que vous comptez les
députés qui ont officiellement
l'étiquette des républicains mais qui en
réalité n'en n'ont pas de candidat en
marche face à eux je prends un exemple
très concret dans ma région quand je
vois eric diard qui comme par hasard n'a
pas de candidat en marche vous croyez
sincèrement que ceux qui votent pour les
républicains vont avoir un candidat
d'opposition ou comme cela s'est passé
dans ma région avec renaud muselier un
candidat qui rejoindra rapidement
emmanuel macron voilà pourquoi par
exemple dans notre région face à eric
diard et bien franck allisio est la
véritable alternative
la réponse fabien de filippo
tous nos candidats se sont une porte nos
couleurs se sont engagés à siéger dans
notre groupe et pas dans un autre et à
deux fidèles à nos valeurs on n'est pas
responsable des investitures ou des noms
investiture de la république aux
remarques de leur capacité à être
présent dans tous les territoires
d'implantation
certains territoires c'est leur problème
nous on leur doit absolument rien donc
aujourd'hui des gens qui sont sous nos
couleurs et d'ailleurs vous avez vu là
où certaines chez nous sont partis sous
d'autres couleurs ils ont des candidats
aient l'air face à eux donc aujourd'hui
les républicains porte une vraie clarté
dans leur projet et on se laissera pas
manipuler par qui que ce soit merci
beaucoup fabien de filippo d'avoir
répondu à nos questions ce soir on jette
un dernier coup d'oeil brigitte ce cette
estimation estime la prochaine assemblée
nationale a en projections de sièges
voilà à quoi pourrait ressembler le
nouveau visage de l'assemblée nationale
dimanche prochain au soir du second tour
estimations de notre partenaire ipsos
sopra et steria avec donc un groupe
ensemble qui serait en tête avec 255 à 2
195 sièges la nuque qui auraient entre
155 à 2 115 sièges ce sont de nouvelles
estimations et les républicains le bloc
de droite entre 50 et 80 sièges le rn 20
à 40 5 sièges et divers 10 à 17 sièges
merci à nous invitait à manon aubry tiré
mariani paul midy merci d'avoir été avec
nous ce soir c'est à la fin de cette
soirée spéciale du premier tour des
législatives
on est à la mi temps on se retrouve pour
la deuxième mi temps dimanche prochain
avec brigitte boucher merci d'avoir
participé à cette émission commune
france info et lcp très bonne soirée à
tous et on se retrouve dimanche prochain
[Musique]